i've gone three times now
and that my ekgs have been wrong
um
you it
[Music]
so
good morning
good morning
foreign
sure
mr rottenberg do you have the reactions
for me we have one of the two the other
one we had to make one tweak two and
we're going to do that electronically
during my cross-examination okay so
which one do you have one uh
so the redactions
reserving your other objections the
redactions are okay yes right okay all
right so 214 will be in evidence
all right do you want to get the witness
back on the witness stand before we get
the jury here yes mr broski
all right let's put her on before we get
the jury out that would be
mr rottenborn you're going to get me 214
after
yes okay
no there's 210 this is 214. yes 210.
okay
we'll put it
all right are we ready for the jury
you ready for the jury yes
so
foreign
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen thank you all right you can
have a seat miss dombroski mr broska i
just want to remind you that you're
still under oath at this time okay all
right you want to continue with your
thank you cross-examination
good morning ms dabrowski good morning
so i believe we we talked a little bit
about this yesterday but you were
in addition to being mr depp's brother
you were his i believe you referred to
it as his personal manager is that right
i have been referred to yes okay and so
you were responsible for
or had some responsibility for his
business affairs right
i actually
coordinated with other people but i
didn't have full responsibility
right but in terms of the information
that you would receive you you would
receive information that was relevant to
mr depp's business affairs and personal
affairs right
at times yes and you you
care about
mr depp's well-being right
yes he's your brother you love him right
it was important to you
that you in your role as both his
brother and as his manager be kept
informed of his well-being right
yes and if something
was wrong you'd want to know about that
right
yes did you ever have reason to believe
from anyone other than amber
that
mr depp had a problem with drugs or
alcohol
no
did you ever have reason to believe from
someone other than amber that mr depp
romanticized drug culture
no
did you ever have reason to believe
from anyone other than amber
that mr deb didn't take accountability
for his actions
i didn't have reason to believe that no
did you ever have reason to believe from
anyone other than amber that mr depp
lacked patience for getting his needs
met
i didn't have reason to believe that now
did you ever have reason to believe from
someone other than amber that mr depp
could act like a child if he didn't get
immediate satisfaction
i'm asking if she had uh overruled i'll
allow it that's fine
let me ask that again
miss dabrowski did you ever have reason
to believe
from anyone other than amber that mr
depp could act like a child if he didn't
get immediate satisfaction
overrule for this question we'll see if
the follow-up okay
i'm sorry
did you ever have reason to believe from
someone other than amber that mr depp
could act like a child if he didn't get
immediate satisfaction
i never had reason to believe that
did you ever have reason to believe from
someone other
than amber that mr depp had fundamental
issues with anger
reason to believe from someone other
than amber
that
your brother had fundamental issues with
anger
i i didn't have reason to believe
and
did you ever have reason to believe from
someone other than amber
that your brother didn't grasp the
responsibility that he had in his
children's lives
i did not have reason to believe
heather can you pull up exhibit 268
please
mrs dombrowski is this an email from dr
david kipper to you on august 18 2014.
it's not being offered yet it's all over
with the objection good
i don't
i don't have it
can can you see the document on your
screen you might have to make it bigger
it's much smaller i i don't i don't have
anything
can you see it there ma'am
no
it's not showing up on her screen
just bear with us one minute thank you
[Music]
do you have a physical copy that she
could look at
not that's not marked up let me um can
you see if i can grab one oh wait she's
got it oh okay
turn it off and on see
that's that's the trick
thank you
to take as much time as you need to read
it ms dombrowski but my my question is
is this a an email from dr david kipper
to you on august 18th 2014.
yes it's got my name on there yes it's
from him
and this is an email that you
um that you would have received on or
about that date august 18 2014
to the best of your knowledge
it was it was sent on that date yes
and it's about dr kipper's treatment of
your brother correct
i'm actually reading it okay take your
time
thank you
do
fine
so
so
is there
i'm sorry is there more to the
there's a there's another page um which
we can go to but my question is just
this
i think we establish this this is an
email that you received from dr kipper
correct
yes okay
um you're on a permission to publish the
um the second paragraph on page one
into the
and then the
the remainder of that paragraph on page
two with everything redacted else
redacted you're asking to enter into
evidence
yes we'd like to enter it into evidence
with those redactions
miss dambrowski if you can take a look
at the first page of that email please
um in the second paragraph
well first of all who was dr kipper
dr kipper was the doctor that was
helping my brother um
excuse me
helping my brother get
help from the uh
the pain medication
addiction that he had he was helping him
with his drug addiction the pain
medication okay
and he your brother was addicted to pain
pills
he had been taking them for a long time
yes right and and you were instrumental
in hiring dr kipper to help
your brother try to deal with that right
yes okay and so dr kipper in his role as
someone treating your brother tried to
to keep you informed of what was going
on with that treatment right
yes and it was important to you as both
his brother i'm his sorry his sister and
his manager that you be kept informed of
that right
it was important as his sister
and well and and his his issues with
drugs were
having an impact on his career as well
too right
no and you knew that they were having an
impact on his relationship with amber
right
she she's given plenty of testimony
about rule don't allow it
you knew that the drugs were having an
impact on his relationship with amber
right
i knew that amber claimed
certain things
but you didn't believe that they were
i didn't necessarily believe it now okay
um
we'll get to that in a few minutes it
isn't it true that
on the bottom paragraph
on page one that dr kipper informed you
that your brother was uncomfortable and
pessimistic that he will ever be able to
stop doing drugs
i'm not not asking for this i'll allow
this question that's the only question
on that
point okay thank you
i'm sorry
isn't it true that
dr kipper informed you in august of 2014
that your brother was uncomfortable and
is pessimistic that he will ever be able
to stop doing drugs
he does write this in this email but
this email is an update
if i'm looking at the dates and i don't
remember all dates but i know that
period
and what's written in the email
i think this was during the time they
were
where he was getting help from dr kipper
right but
that's what he informed you of in your
role as his manager and his sister
about the status of mr depp's
belief that he would be able to stop
doing drugs right
objections
allow that question
i think he was informing me of the
conversations yes
and he also informed you that your your
brother
didn't take accountability for his
behaviors correct
he does say in here
the yes
he wrote that he has no accountability
for his behaviors in this time
and heather can you go to the top of
page two please
in that first and second line he also
told you that your brother has
fundamental issues with anger
right
your honor objection
all right just the same exception that
applied to the other ones this is what
he informed her we need to move on
heather you can take that down
so you just testified um
miss dembrowski that you
understood from amber that drugs and
alcohol were impacting their
relationship but you didn't necessarily
believe that right
right and you didn't necessarily share
those concerns right
right did you have
um
uh an occasion to speak with amber
um
after a plane flight from boston to los
angeles in may of 2014
i just asked if she spoke with her i'm
not asking about the content she spoke
all over the objection at this time
i i don't recall
specific times speaking with amber like
that okay did you become
um did you become aware of an incident
on a plane flight from boston to los
angeles in may of 2014
foundation objection
if you you she's testified that she i'll
sustain the objection of the foundation
if you can lay a foundation
you you if something
if something happened in your brother's
life that was notable
you you wanted to know about it you
testified to that right
yes sir
it's it's a foundation question she's
testified that she had insight into his
daily life
i don't see it as a foundation question
so i'm sustaining the objection if you
want to okay
you
you were kept apprised of the goings on
in johnny's life
correct
for the most part yes yeah and
you testified yesterday you saw him just
about every day correct
when
what i testified to yesterday saw him
every day was when he was with the
family of vanessa and you still saw him
you or were in touch with him fairly
frequently as his business manager and
as a sister when he was with amber
correct
less frequent okay but still with with
some frequency right
yes and if if an event had happened that
was potentially harmful to
your brother you would
you would want to know about that right
yes okay
and
all right i'll sustain asked and
answered next question you want you
you made an effort to
make yourself available to ms heard to
talk to you about issues she was having
with your brother correct
i'm
excuse me i made an effort to talk to
her
anytime i felt she needed to speak
somebody's trying to call us
kind of a pleasant ringtone i didn't
answer it so
i don't know
miss dembrowski
in addition to just amber believing it
you believed that your brother needed
help didn't you
objection
fake
you believed that your brother needed
help with drugs and alcohol over
a
rule objection guys i'm sorry
i i believed on the one medication i was
concerned about
and you wanted your brother to get
better from his addictions right
i wanted to address the medication that
he
was on
and you understood that amber wanted the
same thing
wanted him to get better for both him
and for her correct
speculation
i'll sustain as to what amber wanted
um now do you recall meeting with miss
herd on may 25th
2014.
i don't recall okay
um
let's pull up exhibit 234 please
you said that was 234 234
yes thank you
the non-redacted version
mrs dombrowski this is a multi-page
exhibit that we can
we're not going to ask you about all the
pages but
um
is this
a text message chain between amber and
you
on may 25 2014
yes
and
that those are your texts in gray on the
left right
yes and miss herds texts in blue on the
right
yes
your honor we have a a version of this
exhibit
with ms heard's text redacted and the
personal identifiers redacted
um that i'd like to ask the witness
about
and publish to the jury i'm happy
first you want to admit to evidence
before you publish it
correct right so i'm just previewing
that
would you like me to go through the
unredacted version with the witness
first or
well if it's just her text
how does that
how is that probative if it's just her
text because it's her texts about what
she
two things one it's her texts about what
she wanted for her brother we'll get to
those on page
two um
it's it's i'm allowed to ask her about
her
her own words and what her feelings sort
of you can ask her about it but it's not
coming into evidence okay well okay okay
miss dombrowski
did you reach out to miss heard
on may 25th 2014
yes asking her if she wanted to talk yes
why did you do that i
did you do that because you had been
made aware of an issue about your
brother's behavior on a flight earlier
that day
the day before i don't recall why i did
that
you don't recall why you did that no
you have no no awareness or memory of a
flight earlier that day or the day
before
i don't recall all flights
at all times i don't have any specific
memory of anything
okay
if you can turn to page two heather
if you can look at your third text down
your honor or
miss dembrowski you say
to him
or to misheard
you say to miss heard
i love him so much but he needs help
and i don't have all the information to
help alone do you see that
i'll allow that question that's fine
i do see that and what did you mean when
you said he needs help
i don't recall the actual timing of it
but
i wanted to help him with
the
that medication that he was on that i
know
and i know that
i wanted to be able to be helpful in
life because they were arguing all the
time
and i believe you testified earlier that
you didn't actually have concerns about
your brother's dependence on drugs right
no i said that i did have about the the
medication
just just the pain pills it was the pain
pills nothing else
i didn't have concern
so when you said he needs help that's
what you were referring to is that you
you believe that your brother needed
help with pills
all right
heather can you please pull up um
the the pages ending in
934
start with that please
actually let's let's not let's let's go
to um
936
just for the record this is still an
exhibit 234 it's just bait stamped page
936 is that correct yes your honor okay
miss dembrowski do you see that the
message that you sent to amber three
down where you said he is going to see
the doctor in the morning with three
exclamation points
yes
tell us tell me what you remember about
that were you referring to when you said
he you were referring to your brother
right
yes
and by doctor you meant
an addiction doctor is that right
i i believe i would have meant
dr kipper okay and what was
it's it's it's you'd agree that it's
fairly rare to
get an appointment for a doctor the next
day right
i'll allow it it's fine
i don't know that it's rare to get an
appointment the next day well dr kipper
wasn't an emergency room doctor right
no so what was so urgent about your
brother's need to see a doctor that he
was going to see dr kipper the next
morning when you texted this at 7 35 pm
i don't know that it was urgent i think
i was happy that he was going to see the
doctor and you're happy he was going to
see the doctor because you thought he
finally realized
the problem that his drug addiction was
having on himself and others correct
that's why you were happy right
i was happy he was going to see the
doctor because i was concerned about the
pain medication he was on and you were
concerned about what that pain
medication did to your brother right yes
you were concerned about the effect that
that had on his life right
i was concerned about him and you were
concerned about the effect that that
drug addiction had on other
relationships in his life as well
correct
i'm going through that's fine a lot
you can answer
i didn't see anything that that was
happening necessarily in life to be
concerned about others me
um it was him i was concerned about so
you didn't see your your testimony today
is that you didn't see
any effect that your brother's drug
problem was having on anyone else other
than him my concern was him i wasn't
focused on
anything beyond
that right you weren't you weren't
concerned about the effect that it could
be having on anyone else is that your
testimony
again my concern was him
can you pull up page 937 please
and when you sent misheard the text at
the top of the page at 9 20 p.m on may
25th 2014 and you said i just meant i
will help in getting him help
what did that mean
it's help with dr kipper i believe
you were referring to
getting your brother help for his drug
addictions correct
i was referring to getting him help with
the medication that he was on
and if you go to page 938 please
when you told amber at the bottom of
that page
at 10 30 10 26 p.m i think you need to
tell him you are scared and you can't
deal what did you mean by that
i think you need to tell him you are
scared and you can't deal what did you
mean by that
asking her what she meant with one of
her statements it's no different from
the statement i just asked her about
it
i'm just not sure what the prior
inconsistent statement would be for this
which was
well that she's testified that all of
amber's concerns were overblown
okay
drug abuse you were concerned for your
brother and your brother only is that
right i was concerned for my brother yes
and only your brother is that right
that my brother was my focus
now
you as in your capacity as his personal
manager
you were often
apprised of
your brother's performance on movie sets
right
did you did you have occasion to
communicate with studios for example
about movies that your brother was
shooting
yes and studio executives would could
feel free to contact you about
your brother's work
yes they mostly contacted the agent okay
and you were who was the agent at the
time is that tracy jacobs
and that's the
your brother
mr deb fired miss jacobs
in in around 2017 is that right i don't
recall when how long was ms jacobs his
agent
20 something years
and he fired miss jacobs at some point
right
yes after his divorce from amber
i don't recall exactly when he fired her
do you recall whether it was before or
after he divorced amber
i don't recall
but in any event you had frequent
communications with miss jacobs about
your brother's work correct excuse me um
yeah
and you
um
in the course in in your capacity as his
his manager
it came to your attention that he was
late to movie sets correct
you testified that you had
contact with
frequent contact with ms jacobs his
agent right
yes and that contact included when he
was shooting movies
yes and that contact included
communications relating to his conduct
on set
i'm laying definition
well it sounds like your foundation is
going to be based on hearsay which is
what we're going to be getting to well
if you can lay a foundation without it
being based on hearsay did you have
personal knowledge of your brother being
late to a set
movie shoots
was i
would that be if i was physically there
is that what you're asking
or
you're on a no first i'd instruct i'd
ask you to interrupt mr chu not to
shake his head and nod his head to the
witness that's inappropriate
okay well he was
all right well i'll keep a lookout thank
you
all right thank you miss dambrowski your
brother told you himself
that he was late to movie shoots didn't
he
party
i'll allow them
i don't i don't think he came to me and
said i'm late to movie shoots no you
learned from your brother that he
was late to movie shoots correct
i i don't think he would have come to me
to talk about it allow it
you learned
so so you never had any communications
with your brother about
issues that he had being on time to
movie sets is that your testimony
no
what i'm saying is is i worked with him
for years you know there was never a
really a continuous topic of
whether he was late to a movie set him
and i having a conversation
he told you he had been late to movie
sets correct
i'll sustain the objection next question
can you pull up 348 please 348.
um
if you can can you blow it up so you
just see the second email down heather
and that second email down is an email
from you to tracy jacobs on february 27
2015 right
i allowed that question we'll see where
we go
the second
all the way down in here
the second one down from the top
sent at 12 50.
oh
sorry
yes that's from me too crazy
okay
now
in the second sentence of that email
you write he told me one to one and a
half hours but not two yes he was two
and a half hours late one day and seven
hours recently do you see that
i do see that
and when you said he told me you're
referring to your brother
johnny depp admitting to you that he was
late to movie sets right i don't know
that i'm referring to him now okay
uh in any event it was a problem
is his personal manager you knew that it
was a problem for the studios if he
showed up late to set right
i knew that on this particular film
there were times when he was late to set
you did know on this particular film
and this was this particular film is
pirates five correct
yes pirates of the caribbean five
and he was filming that in australia
right yes
and this email was sent on february 27
2015 right
yes okay so you knew that as he was
filming pirates of the caribbean five on
in 2015 early 2015 that he had problems
being late to the set right
i wouldn't call it problems being late
to set but he was occasionally late to
set okay uh
late enough that disney executives
called you
to discuss that right
all right
i'll sustain the objection next question
and you knew that this wasn't the only
movie that he had been late to set for
correct
she's testified about her close
involvement in
his personal affairs when he was
shooting movies
maybe if you lay a foundation not based
on hearsay
have you
you talked to your brother
when he was filming each of the movies
that he filmed right
yes okay and with respect to pirates
five he told you that he had been late
to the set right
no i don't recall him telling me he was
late to set okay so despite the fact he
said he told me you don't recall whether
that was him or not
i don't know that that
i don't know that the he in that refers
to him
okay
you
you were also i believe you testified
yesterday that you were closely involved
in um
in the financial aspects of your
brother's life right
i was i was closely involved in speaking
with the representatives but i wasn't
really closely involved in
you know his financial world i had that
wasn't my thing and
your brothers the income
that he made from
movies or
other commercial opportunities that he
had
that
funded both him and it flowed or it came
in through his companies right and then
the money that your brother made came in
through his companies correct
i'm i don't really understand your
question well you're the president of
one of those companies infinitive nile
right yes so if your brother signs a
movie contract the money is it paid
directly to him or does it come in
through through a company
that he's owns
infinite is completely a separate entity
so
how he gets paid is that's the business
managers
okay you you were involved with
um
discussions of opportunities that he had
to shoot movies correct
sometimes yes
and you were
um
in close contact with others on mr
depp's team about opportunities that
arose right
yes okay including tracy jacobs yes his
agent
yes including
um
you in fact you would be in contact with
studios directly as well it's from time
to time right
yes
and mr jacobs um
well
strike that
in your capacity as his
personal manager
you became aware
of
financial distress that your brother was
in correct because you you were familiar
with his financial affairs right
i was somewhat familiar that was
that was the other representatives area
okay did you have occasion to become
familiar with whether he was undergoing
financial distress such that he needed
to get movies a certain number of movies
a year
i
tracy had
a certain number excuse me a certain
number of movies per year that she
wanted him to do
and the certain number of movies a year
to your understanding the certain number
of movies a year that your brother had
to do was necessary to
stave off financial distress correct
the certain number of movies per year
would tracy would push for a certain
number of movies per year because
it was it was beneficial
to her
that that's the only reason she pushed
for a certain number of movies a year
that's the main reason tracy would push
for a certain number of movies per year
yes
not not because it was beneficial to mr
deb
if it was beneficial to mr death then it
was going to be beneficial to tracy okay
but just because it was beneficial to
tracy doesn't mean it wasn't beneficial
to mr death or his companies
correct
i'll sustain the objection next question
now at some point you became aware when
he was filming pirates 5 in australia
you became aware of an injury that he
suffered to his finger
right yes
and
you were
involved
in
trying to cover up how it happened
correct objection
i'll allow the question
i'm not sure i understand the question
you were involved in helping to cover up
how the finger injury happened right
i i i don't understand cover-up
you you were
you were involved in
making sure that people on mr depp's
team didn't say how he hurt his hand
correct
um
we certainly didn't want
um
any press to know about it so that's
you know to keep it from that
um
and and because you didn't want any
press to know about his finger injury
you
told mr depp's personal assistant to
make sure that he wasn't to say that he
wasn't sure how mr depp hurt his hand
correct
you instructed him to say that
if it was someone that
i would be concerned that the
word would get out to the press i would
have done that
so
it was
it was okay
to you to tell people to lie to protect
your brother right
it wasn't necessarily a lie i didn't
know how he
hurt his finger
myself at the time
because i
i'm pretty sure i know the time frame
you're talking about
is when it first happened
and you have no personal knowledge to
this day of how he hurt his finger
correct
because you weren't there
i wasn't there
heather can you pull up exhibit 210
redacted please
your honor this is um the exhibit we
discussed yesterday um
if
the court and
mr two agrees with the redactions i'd
just like to publish it to the jury uh
and admit it into evidence well if it's
two tenets already
in in evidence that that's when you gave
me this morning correct no that's a
different one yeah i think that was 214.
that was 214. i'm sorry i got them
backwards this is 2 10.
and i believe that this
is this is just one page
or it's two it's two pages i'm sorry
yeah it's these two pages that we talked
about yesterday
all right reserving your objections are
the redactions correct
okay that's fine
i will enter a 214 into evidence
over over objections permission to
publish
yes sir thank you
can you blow that up please
so miss dambrowski
we discussed this a little bit yesterday
this is
the text exchange between you and miss
heard on february 3rd 2014
where miss heard says jd is on a bender
and your your response is where are the
kids correct
yes and just scroll down please
let's go to the next page please
scroll down to the bottom please
and then you
text amber worry about everything
is that right
i wrote the words worry about everything
was myself i was speaking about myself
and you tell her i don't love any of it
correct right
and
sustained we we did go through this
yesterday but go ahead and and two days
later is when you sent your brother the
text messages that said
stop booze stop coke stop pills correct
i'm not looking at it i don't recall the
timing of it
nothing further thank you all right
redirect
yes
okay thank you
good morning ms timbroski good morning
during mr rottenborn's examination
yesterday and again this morning
he spent a lot of time talking to you
about your brother's alleged drug and
alcohol abuse you remember that yes
you're not denying that mr depp ever
used alcohol or drugs are you
objection leading
let's redirect your honor
that's still leading um i'll sustain
this leading if you want to rephrase
your question
you also testified uh several times in
response to mr rottenborn's questions
that miss heard
tends to say things in a more dramatic
manner do you recall that testimony yes
why did you say that
i've had my own interaction
one-on-one with miss heard so i know
i know a bit about her personality um
she would you know she would present
information to me
um
that was not necessarily
information that was supported by
everybody else that was around and and
i've spent a lot of years working with
my brother we have a close team we've
you know it's a many years of trusted
people helping you know
make sure that everything in life it
works out and goes smoothly
but all those people where i would have
a daily contact
you know whether it's about scheduling
or just how the day is going for all the
years
those people never said the same thing
objection here say your honor i think it
was responsive to the question well i'll
sustain the last the last sentence
yeah because
there's the last sentence of it that's
all understood
i think it goes to state of mind rather
than the truth i just did the last
sentence i'll sustain just the last
sentence
okay
and do you recall your testimony
yesterday
when you stated that
after the phenomenal success of pirates
one
one of the changes to mr dapps your
brother's personal life was that there
were a lot more people around him after
that do you recall that yes
when johnny and miss heard became
involved in a relationship
several years later
were there still
several people were there still a lot of
people around them
your brother on a regular basis
yes
who were those people he had he had
assistance he had security he had you
know
property managers people that helped at
the house
there he had
quite a few people that were around all
the time
how often did you communicate with those
people
um i communicated daily not necessarily
with each one of those people but i
communicated pretty much daily with
people within
the world the circle
did any of those people
ever raise the same concerns that ms
heard did objection hearsay
all right
again it goes to state of mind i'll
sustain the objection as to here next
question
what if any
concerns were expressed about johnny's
behavior
when using alcohol objection hearsay
all right again it goes to state of mind
i'll sustain the objection next question
thank you honor that's all i have all
right is this witness subject to recall
i do not believe so your honor she's
subject to recall no no all right mr
brusca you're free to go or you can stay
in the courtroom it's up to you okay
thank you all right thank you ma'am
thank you very much mr nambroski
all right your next witness
good morning ma'am
isaac
all right
we'll get him okay that's right thank
you
while we're waiting for him can you
spell his last name for the court
reporter for me uh b-a-r
thank you
so
so
um
do you swear or affirm to testify
truthfully in this case on the penalty
of the law
[Music]
hey there's a thing here transcript you
can just keep it there sir have a seat
put the microphone
close to you please thank you
good morning
would you state your name for the record
please uh my name is isaac baruch
i-s-a-a-c-b-a-r-u-c-h
mr brooch where do you currently live i
live in los angeles
do you know the plaintiff in this case
johnny depp yes
how do you know mr depp
i know i'm from since teenagers we met
in
florida and could you tell the jury a
little bit about your experience meeting
mr depp when you were teenagers in
florida
yeah
we were both playing in bands
we had mutual friends
and
that we met in probably 1980
and uh
yeah we hit it off we got along with
each other
and uh yeah
how often did you see mr depp when you
were teenagers together in florida
a few times a few times a month i'd say
it could be more a little more or
whatever because you know we see each
other at parties and clubs nightclubs
with the bands played
yeah like that
and for how long were you both living in
florida and seeing each other somewhat
regularly
well we
we met in like 1980 so
uh
and then we both moved away he moved to
california i moved to new york
was that 80
from 80 to 83 that was that like four
years
what were your impressions of mr depp
while you were um both living in florida
at the same time oh he's he's a sweet
kid
a sweet guy
sir wait there's an objection oh thank
you what his impressions were back then
what's the relevance just establishing
the background in the relationship
you're under also staying the objection
next question please all right
um
mr brooch did there come a time when mr
depp uh moved away from florida
yeah yeah and where did he move to if
you know like i said before you moved to
california
at some point in time did you also move
to california
yeah
and did you um reconnect with mr depp
when you got there
yeah
around what time was that
sometime during the first year and
uh
then afterwards after the first year of
more
and stuff
yeah
about what year would you say that was
oh i moved to california in uh
september of uh 85.
and did you know um if mr depp was
working when you arrived in california
in 1985 well i knew i knew he was
pursuing acting
at that time yeah
he's looking for work because he's
pursuing acting
how often did you see uh mr depp when
you first moved to california
well like i said the first year
a few times afterwards
i had a friend who uh whose girlfriend
uh lived in the same building as johnny
and that so then hanging out over there
i ended up seeing johnny more often and
plus my friend who i who i'm talking
about who
whose girlfriend lived in the same
building he was playing in a band and
they needed another guitar player and
johnny ended up joining the band
so
we were hanging out a lot more often
um what were you doing when you moved
out to california
i was pursuing music also
working retail jobs and trying to
[Music]
get a band ever make a band you know
did there come a time when you begin
working for mr depp
oh yeah yeah yeah when was that
oh that's later on that's like in 1993.
what were you doing for mr depp when you
started working for him in 1993
well he owned a place called the viper
room
and uh which is a music venue uh
nightclub bar and bands play
and uh
it was already open for six months
and uh the girl who was working the
the person who was working the as office
manager didn't want to work there
anymore so the guy who was running the
place for johnny who's a friend named
saljenko another florida friend from
back in 1980 when we all first meet
he calls me up and he says hey isaac do
you want to work this job
i don't think it's offered for the truth
of the matters
that's fine i'll overrule the objection
go ahead
at some point in time did you stop
working at the viper room for mr depp oh
yeah when was that
well i worked from 93 to 98
in 98 i moved away
did you return to la again at some point
yes i did when was that
i moved back uh december of 2002.
what did you do for work when you
returned to la well for two weeks i
worked at an art gallery and then i uh
went back to the viper room on new
year's eve
how long were you working at the viper
room at that point in time it was
another year and then the place changed
hands
were you working
on anything else while you were working
at the viper room in that time frame
yeah
i was work
sideways i was teaching myself art
and what steps were you taking to teach
yourself art at that time
books learning how to draw and uh paint
and uh taking community uh college
classes
at some point in time did you uh begin
pursuing art at a on a full-time scale
yeah yeah yeah how did that come about
well i was working at working at the
viper room taking classes and then at uh
at one point the club
changed hands completely after a year
2004
and
i was given a choice of either keep
working for these new owners or
uh johnny out of his pocket was going to
give a severance pay to whoever didn't
want to work there
anymore so i took the severance pay and
then it helped me continue on to
to finish community classes private
classes and then be able to transfer to
uh cal state university
and did you get a degree from cal state
university yes i did what degree was
that bfa what year
2010
after you received your bfa did you
continue to pursue art full-time
yeah
did mr depp ever express an interest in
your art
yeah
when was the first time that happened
well first time you saw a painting in
2008
and then the next time was 20 uh
2012
uh i had uh made a painting and sent it
to my best friend the
email uh in an email
and uh he forwarded it to johnny and
johnny emailed back saying hey when
isaac wants to sell that
whenever he wants to sell that to go
ahead and
get in touch with me because i want to
buy it
did mr depp ever buy that painting no
why not
because when i brought over paintings i
i had moved back to uh california and i
brought over a bunch of paintings for
him to look at and see if he wants any
to buy by onions he
looked at me and says i got an idea how
about i be your patron
and we put together an art show
make some make make a body of work and
then we'll i'll throw a party and invite
people and
i'll sell the stuff for you and you
could keep all the money
so he didn't he didn't buy any paintings
there instead he offered me a complete
patron ship
so what did you understand he meant by
becoming your patron
what was going to financially make it
possible for me to just paint every day
and put together a body of work so that
way then it could be sold
how did he plan to do that
objection to what he planned on doing
what did you understand he planned to do
to make that possible for you i could
tell you i could tell you that
uh it inc and what it included was that
the next day
i ended up moving into here he
i moved into a uh art studio penthouse
at the eastern columbia building it was
listen i got a place for you to go ahead
and
live and work and put this body of of
art together and uh i'll take care of
you you don't have to worry about
anything and what was the place where
you were going to live that mr depp
offered you the eastern columbia
building did you um did you take him up
on that offer to live at the eastern
columbia building yeah of course
and uh how did that make you feel
i started crying is you know
one day
one day you're in your mother's garage
selling paintings for a hundred dollars
two hundred dollars three hundred
dollars on ebay next thing you know you
get your it's an art show and like you
don't have to worry about deadly squad
of course of course i was i was flipping
out
when did you move into the eastern
columbia building
the next day after we met and we talked
the next day
the next day
i guess i get a phone call from a guy
named kevin murphy who is working for
johnny and i go to and he says hey meet
me at this address
and i go and i meet him and here i am in
front of this building is a beautiful
building this is like you know it's
whatever 13 floors but it's like from
the 1930s some art deco
beautiful building and i'm looking i'll
go all right this is unreal what there's
going to be
you know all right it's going to be one
of these apartments or whatever one of
these places here
i go in with uh kevin murphy he takes me
all the way up to the roof
we go we go
into penthouse 2. and this
i walk in and i'm like crying and going
this is a
it's beautiful this is like a
a mansion uh situation to me mr bridge
how long did you end up living at the
eastern columbia building
three years and seven months
um your honor i'd like to show the
witness plaintiff's exhibit 116. all
right 116.
am i looking at something you will in a
second sir
it's not ice cream
okay lunchtime
so
oh
paper copy
i'm just going to pull up a paper copy
for a moment
we can see it but he can't
all right thank you we'll just use the
paper copy we'll get this resolved at
lunch time okay thank you your honor
mr brooch do you recognize the document
um that you're looking at that's been
marked as plaintiff's exhibit 116
yeah
what and what is it
this is uh the floor plan of the roof uh
all the penthouses up on uh
on the roof at uh
the eastern columbia and that's the
building where you lived um starting in
march 2013 is that right
i moved in the first week of march uh
2013. yeah your honor at this time i'd
like to move into um evidence planish
exhibit 116 please no objection you're
on all right 116 in evidence you can
publish to the jury
is it i'm sorry i just want to be sure
that yeah they can see it in the gallery
we'll just have to work on that screen
thank you your honor
uh mr brooch can you um describe for the
jury what um is depicted here in exhibit
116
uh yeah that uh so the right side of
this uh
graph is uh there's a pool there there's
a uh there's a another
top of another apartment that actually
starts on the floor below it's a
two-story apartment
um but there's a pool there and there's
a uh
gem workout room and the left side
is uh
at the bottom
there's an x and that's uh
the elevator
and so you walk out of the elevator you
make a little uh left
and there's part of penthouse five right
there straight ahead
and then you keep walking straight and
then you make a left
a sharp left and the actual penthouse
five is straight ahead
and then you hang a right
and you
start walking up that way on your right
is gonna be penthouse one on your left
is gonna be penthouse four
when you get to the end of that
corridor this is the door for penthouse
three
and if you hang a right
oh look there it is it came up on the
screen
and if you hang a right
and you go down to the end is the door
to penthouse two that's the apartment
that i lived in
and who did you understand own these
penthouses oh johnny owned them all
which one did you live in penthouse 2.
was anyone else living in the penthouses
at the time that you moved in in march
2013
no i was the first one to move in i
moved in the first week of march
and then a couple of weeks later
two three weeks later then johnny and
amber moved in
and then after that
the next one to move in is rocky
raquel pennington amber's a friend
and then at some point her sister moved
in whitney
and uh also uh at some point uh rocky's
uh
boyfriend
moved in with her
in penthouse one
so i believe he just testified that uh
mr depp and ms hurd moved in uh shortly
after you moved in is that right yes and
which penthouse did they move into
penthouse 3.
and then you testified i believe that um
someone named rocky pennington moved in
yes who was rocky pennington
amber heard's friend from texas and i i
think they made them i don't know i'm
not sure if they told me that they moved
out there together or something like
that but um
yeah her friend
and later you said that um her boyfriend
moved in with her what was his name
josh josh drew
and which unit did they live in
penthouse one
and i believe you also testified that um
whitney moved in who was whitney
whitney uh hurt
she's married so she's got a different
last name i'm not sure what it is but uh
amber's sister whitney and which of the
units did
miss misheard sister live in
four
um can you tell the jury a little bit
about your relationships um with ms
heard um miss pennington mr drew um and
miss
her um
sister oh yeah i
i was friends with all of them i loved
them all they all treated me with
respect this we had
it was great uh you know i'm an all-time
friend of johnny's living
living there and we're all looking out
for each other we became great friends i
fell in love with
all of them
when you moved in um to penthouse two
you were working on an art show with mr
depp right
yeah that that's the entire reason that
i'm there is to the to
work
and put together this art show
did you have a time frame that you
expected to be able to put on that art
show
at first when we first power out this
idea when you know
it's
we talked about all right what do we do
you know what's what's this show going
to be what how many paintings is is it
going to be and we came up with a number
okay there's going to be a certain body
of work i'm not i'm not a known person
i'm just some schnook painter it's so
there's and
if i was a famous painter i could make
five paintings and and the room will
fill up but so we decided okay like 25
pieces of work large scale and i would
and johnny says hey what how long do you
think this will take i said i've never
done it before i don't know maybe a few
months
and were you able to compete complete
the paintings in the in a few months no
it's it's
after it took me to in order to make two
large-scale paintings it took me like uh
to almost two months
and i'm i'm start freaking out going
i'm only got two paintings and all right
i got to do 25 i said a few months so i
ended up going to johnny's place and and
saying hey look
dude this is going to take a lot longer
than of a
a few months i could only make two
paintings and how did mr depp react he
looks at me and he starts laughing and
he says ike
don't worry i do not care i just want
you to paint however long it takes just
i want you to paint every day
during the course of time that you were
living at the eastern columbia building
um did mr depp ever give you any money
yeah
how much did he give you
over a period of four years
of the patron ship
i ca i ballpark it calculated probably
around 100 000.
and how did you come up with that amount
well
from the first from the first get-go
when i say hey look i need though you
know to buy stuff and and and to you
know
do this
he i ended up getting an envelope the
next day with five thousand dollars in
it
and then i budgeted it and
and stretched it out and you know and so
every few months i'd
i'd get an envelope it could have that i
didn't know if it was going to be the
same amount but it ended up being the
same amount which was
wow uh so basically around five grand
every few months so in a year it's 20
grand but then also there was a per uh
maybe a year or two might have been that
it was five times i had to ask
for for dough or it was four and then on
top of it so
so right there that's could be 80 grand
or 90 grand and then on top of that
i ended up
getting a
herniated disc he sent me to the doctors
to get an mri and and see the doctor get
an mri and there was 10 weeks of of
therapy
that he covered so i throw that in there
too and i ended up coming up with the
figure 100 100 grand could be a little
less could be a little more
what was your understanding of whether
mr depp intended to be paid back for
that money that he provided to you
there's no it's
that's not even the thought of being
paid back this is something that he
wanted to see happen this is something
he he invested in to to he knew he had
to he was going to spend money to make
it happen for me to survive and paint
and create this thing that he wanted to
see because he liked the art
and so there was and there was no
payback and the the whole thing was
about
him
selling the art so that way i could put
so that way i keep all the money he
didn't expect anything it was he was
doing this as a friend as he's done with
many other friends
i'll sustain the last sentence of his
his statement
explain to the jury that striking means
we've done that but that's fine thank
you thank you your honor
uh mr brooch did there come a time when
you um decided that you planned to pay
mr depp back oh yeah
that
for me
when uh
when
he
he's told me he had a money situation
going on
for me it was like this guy just changed
he's been
he's been making it possible for me to
live and work and and and make product
and that and
and i'm by that expense i'm part of the
problem it's like how do i help him how
can i help him i mean he's sharing his
sandwich with me
you know
it's like if i how do i how do i share
that my hair my sandwich with him give
him that half to make something up
that's it's
you you don't you don't not do anything
and said the only thing i got is
paintings
so i
i stood up when he
he's telling me what he's telling me
about his money situation and for me i
said hey it's this is if these things
ever sell we got to split this 50 50 and
i ain't taking no for an answer
something i got to add i got to put
something into this
so as
for me
i looked at it like he's got it he has
to get something back
broods during your time living at the
eastern columbia building did you
develop a relationship uh with the
defendant in this case ms heard
yeah
and did you get along with miss hurd i
loved her i fell in love with her just
like johnny fell in love with her i fell
in love with her she's
totally respectful gracious to me
uh that she's got great teeth
that
she treated me with complete respect
any time i walk into the sheets at the
humor wise
totaled uh locker a locker room humor
demented humor totally laughed at you
know the jokes
uh made the jokes totally got along with
her every time i walked into that place
isaac you want something to eat isaac
you want something to drink every time
there's only one time i remember
that she didn't offer because i walked
in and she's in the kitchen at the
counter and she's doing a beauty facial
mask and uh so she can't offer me and
i'm going hey is that something that can
help me and she looked at me and she
goes no
and that
and i'm laughing and then she left after
because she didn't realize she was
making a joke
so
um yeah i loved her mr burch did miss
herd ever visit you in your penthouse
yeah
do you recall the first time that she
visited you there yes when was that the
first time is that
it's in march
when they moved in
and they were there for a
couple of days and i didn't even know
and johnny had called me says hey come
over meet my girl and that and then the
and so i did and then the next day they
came over to my place
uh for the first time to see how i had
set up the art studio the lights and you
know just what's my
painting set up and stuff and to look at
other paintings and they walked in and i
remember the first thing she said was i
hope we didn't keep you up last night
because of all the yelling
and i
looked at her and says no these walls
are like three feet thick i don't hear
deadly squad
how did she seem when she said that to
you
well she's is it semi-joking and
inquisitive you know like you they did
you know to find out
um in your three and a half years living
at the eastern columbia building did you
have opportunities to observe mr depp's
and miss herd's uh relationship
yeah
can you describe uh what you observed
about their relationship
they were always loving with each other
they treated each other like gold
you know
kissing and and you know can what can i
get you type of thing you know
being kind with each other
always loving always a loving situation
how often would you say you interacted
with mr depp and ms hurd
if they were there
because they're traveling they're doing
they're working and doing stuff if they
were there i saw them maybe two three
times a week could maybe the others
there might be one time one time a week
that i see them that i go over to hang
out or
you know
see them or they might come or
johnny might come over to visit or you
know
like that
since you've known them um did you ever
see them get physically violent with
each other no
did you ever see them argue
yes
how many times
probably like twice okay um can you
describe the arguments that you
witnessed
the first argument that i remember was
walking in uh
there was a
it was a telephone argument
johnny's at the kitchen table and he's
argue he's he's
he's screaming about something and on
the other line because it's on speaker
and he's talking with the phone at the
phone
uh
the other person is is amber
and that she's in new york
and he's uh at the kitchen table
and uh they're arguing
and he's going who is it who is it and
she's saying oh baby come on please
don't what are you doing baby why are
you being like this baby
and this went on for a little while and
i'm listening and then he hangs up
she calls back again and it's the same
thing who is it what's going on who is
it and she's she's saying oh come on
baby don't be woody what are you doing
baby and and then
hang up the phone again the third time
it happens i'm saying this there's no
solution in this conversation i grabbed
the phone from him and i says hey amber
this is isaac listen this conversation
is now over and i hung up the phone
and
she didn't call back again and he went
to the couch and went to bed
i believe you said you saw them argued
twice was there another time that you
saw them argue uh i ended up going over
and there's at the kitchen table is
johnny is amber is uh rocky and josh
and they're pa and i'm going what are
you guys doing and they're hanging out
and they're power
trying to plot
to figure out a way how to get rid of
whitney to not live there anymore
and i felt bad i like whitney says you
know oh well you know that's that's
going to be a drag
and uh
i just i
you know what are you plotting you know
how do you figure out hey lend your
sister some dough and let her move out
but you know they're trying to figure
something out
something differently or whatever at one
point so there was a point johnny got
completely
you know
flustered and and frustrated and he got
up and he walks away and as he's walking
away he says figure it out
and that was it that was the whole thing
i don't know if you want to call i don't
think you uh might call that an argument
but
your honor i'm about to um switch gears
a little bit and make a good time for a
mid morning perfect thank you all right
ladies and gentlemen go ahead and have
you take your morning recess for 15
minutes okay just remember to not talk
to anybody and do not do any outside
research okay and we'll see you back
here in 15 minutes
you can stay right here that's fine
thank you
all
right sir i just want to remind you
since you're still on the stand under
you can't talk to any of the attorneys
or mr hurt this time until your
testimony is done okay okay all right
and we'll be back and we'll be back at
11 45 okay i got to stay here though
yeah you have
oh okay
oh okay
you
you can stay you can stay inside
all right
okay yes ma'am your next question
mr baruch where are you back
thank you for coming back yes um were
you still living in penthouse 2 of the
eastern columbia building on may 21st
2016 yes
do you recall what you were doing that
evening
yes
what were you doing i was out it was
evening time i'm out in the neighborhood
and i'm on my way home i get a phone
call from my friend
who wants to know if i want to go out
and eat i said i just ate but uh i'm
five minutes away from
from the eastern columbia building home
and then go across the street get
something to eat
and uh bring it up
for take out and we'll go upstairs to my
joint and
we'll eat and yeah did you meet your
friend back at the eastern columbia
building yeah around what time was that
9 30.
what happened after you met your friend
we went upstairs
can we pull up plaintiff's exhibit 116
again please
in your honor given that this has
already been
admitted i ask that it be published
all right that's fine you can publish it
you just can't see it
okay he still has it
mr burch is it on the screen in front of
you
yeah okay great yes
mr brooch i'm going to ask you a couple
of questions about what happened after
you went upstairs that evening um and it
may be helpful for you there are
controls on that screen um that you can
use to sort of mark
the exhibit to show the jury that the
spots that you're talking about and
identifying so if you just touch it
it'll make a mark so you don't have to
touch the top that's fine
do i touch something on manual here nope
you don't know just wait and you can
touch it whenever she needs you to mark
it just wherever i touch it it's going
to make them all it will okay
thank you
mr burj when you got upstairs that
evening with your friend around 9 30
what did you see
we got out of the elevator and you know
just like in the graph you you make a
left and then you turn the corner
when we walked out i noticed on the
floor there's uh charge of glass there's
pieces of glass and so you know it's
just looking going oh something busted
could be one of the sconces or something
like that and
kept walking can you mark on the exhibit
where you saw the broken glass that
evening
yeah
right there
right where you could go left or you
could go right and if you wanted to go
to the pool area that's you could
there's a exit that way so you could
either go right till you go left you go
left you're in the apartment going in
the hallway through the apartments or
you go right right there in that spot
and did you continue on to your
penthouse after you saw the broken glass
oh yeah so we walk walk around
and then we make the turn
we hang the right
past the penthouse five and we stopped
right in front of
right here
what and why did you stop right there
oh stopped in front of here
penthouse one
which is much more
right there
because there's this puddle of wine
huge puddle of wine on the floor that's
in front of the door and there's a
wine uh the splashed wine that's
dripping down the wall
and so we stopped
and i'm looking and going look at this
this is someone must have got hammered
these guys probably had a party
and and at that point right then as soon
as i said that
the door opens up
and it's josh drew
who pokes his head out the door only
enough for his head to come out
and he's pretty bug-eyed and it looks
distraught
and i look at him and i go
what's up with the spilled wine
and
i figured i'd get an explanation or
whatever
and uh he says he looked at me and just
said rough day had a rough day
and at that point i got concerned
and
said to him because i'm friends with
with him
you know i got concerned said hey you
okay you want me to help you with
something do you need help he said no
it's okay we got it
and i said okay
and i me and my buddy took off
and went into my place
and what did you do after that
he my buddy ate uh i believe he had
pizza from across the street and uh we
talked we yapped for a while and you
know it could be i could yap so it could
you know it could take we were there
probably hour and change or something
like that
and then uh
you know we're done so it's i walked
i walked them out
and walked down
went to the elevator walked out went to
the elevator we went downstairs i walked
them out the door finished to finish the
conversation that we were having
and i said all right see ya and then i
went back in
i went upstairs and i
went to bed
around what time was that that you went
back into the eastern columbia building
you know something is is if
we got there like around 9 30 and we
we're talking
i don't know an hour to an hour and a
half
two hours
you know somewhere around 11 o'clock i
would think
we can go ahead and take
exhibit 116 down
mr baruch can you
describe for the jury the events of the
next day may 22nd 2016. yes
it's my birthday may 22nd is my birthday
i wake up
i end up
texting
johnny and saying hey i'm gonna be in
town because he's not staying at the at
the eastern columbia building he's
staying in a house in in town okay
and uh so i texted him it's my birthday
i said listen i'm gonna be in town
uh i'm gonna come by and to uh to have a
birthday drink okay
i didn't hear from him you know i didn't
get an answer back but i said that's
what i'm doing if that happens that
happens
but
so it was
around
noon noon time
uh that so i left i walked out of my
apartment and i go through the hallway
as you see the graph
i go through the hallway and i turn the
corner from penthouse 3 and
uh
as i'm walking down
who do i see it's a group of people
it's a guy in black clothes
uh
a
black shirt black pants
amber heard
and i see josh drew
who's leaning up against the door and
the door is open this door is open
something's going on and as i'm walking
up
i'm saying hey what's up what are you
guys doing
and then amber turns to me as i'm
walking up amber turns to me and she
says
uh johnny came by last night he got
violent so i'm changing the locks on one
three and five
and i'm look at her and and she goes oh
and don't worry about two you're okay
and at this point i'm now walking past
so now we're all in front of this of the
open door
of the apartment and i see there's two
guys two locksmiths working on the door
so
now
i'm standing on one side and yeah you
have josh drew
on one side of the door you got the two
locksmiths with the door open working on
it some lights this the sun's coming
through the door sunlight from windows
and then amber isn't is in front of me
and there's the security guy
and and that with two feet away from
each other
talking and she introduces me as she as
she's finishing saying uh oh don't worry
about your uh your apartment she says oh
and this is a security guard that i got
that who's gonna be hanging around
and she i got introduced she introduced
me to him and i shook his hand he gave
me a card which i lost and uh
and that
and
i'm kind of taking this in and going and
i said wait
what what happened
what's what's going on
and
uh
at that point
josh drew
looks at me and gives me the high sign
to like hey i'll you know follow me
i'll uh
i'll tell you in private
and
when you were speaking with miss heard
how close were you standing to her
like i said
two i'm two feet
a foot and a half two feet away
we're all
two feet
and how was the lighting in that area
there's lights in the hallway but we're
standing and we're standing in an open
doorway that the wall this uh is all
windows
sunlight's coming through and
you can operate in this light there's
that much light
did you notice any marks on her face
when you were speaking with her no
did you see any bruises no did you see
any redness no did you notice any
swelling
no
did it look like miss heard was wearing
any makeup
no had you seen her wearing makeup
before yeah
and you had seen her not wearing makeup
before yeah i seen like i said with fate
doing with the face mask doing a face
mask no makeup hanging around the uh
waking up in the morning
uh no uh uh with makeup glammed out to
go out
three and a half years seeing her in
different different forms
did you speak with mr drew about
anything at that point
well yeah after i said that uh
uh
hey what's going on
and he gave me the high sign to like hey
follow him we went into my apartment and
had a conversation and what happened um
after you had that conversation with mr
drew
we left the apartment and we we go
walking back
uh towards a penthouse one and as i'm
walking back i'm i say to amber as i'm
walking up he hit you
and she goes yeah he threw a phone at me
and hit me
and i'm looking because i had just seen
her
two feet away and i'm going where
and she puts her head out she puts a
face out like that for me to look at the
right side of her face
and i'm looking but at that point also
i'm looking and i turn i turn around get
on the other side we're in the doorway
so i'm on this side with the light
shining this way from the doorway with
the lights above and but the sunshine
and she's got a face out like this
looking
you know to show me and i'm looking and
i just go i inspect the face
i'm looking at a forehead i'm looking at
the side of a side of her eye i'm
looking at her cheek i'm looking at her
chin i'm looking at the other side of
the face i'm looking at the whole thing
and i don't see
anything
i don't see anything to
i don't see a
cut a bruise swelling redness it's just
amber's face that she's going like this
and show me
so
i'm not seeing anything
i back up and i'm making a joke
i make a joke going well i don't see
anything but maybe all the beauty from
one side of your face to the other side
of the face is outshining everything so
i can't see anything
and she's laughed and she's you know
smiled
and i just looked at everybody and said
hey
this it sounds nuts
and i went and i gave i said i gotta go
and i gave her a hug and kissed her on
that side of the face kissed her on that
side of her face and then i left
said goodbye what was her reaction when
you kissed her on that side of the face
nothing
did she flinch no
you see ms hurd again the next day
yeah
yeah yeah when was that
so that's monday that was may 22nd my
birthday
then the next day
is uh
monday
the 23rd
i had woken up
uh with a chest cold and i heard a knock
on the door and it's amber
so
i opened up the door around what time
was that that's i want to say
maybe
around
maybe around noon time maybe a little
bit before
maybe it could have been a little bit
i think around noon time again
and uh
i went downstairs and i opened up the
door and when you opened the door did
you have a good view of miss heard
absolutely yeah how was the lighting
lighting's fine lighting from from
outside and there's light from
my place yeah so
this is the lighting was great
did you see any marks on misheard's face
at that time no same thing like the the
the day before
there's no redness there's no swelling
there's no bruises there's no cuts
there's no none this is the amble
looking like amber
did you notice if she was wearing any
makeup at that point
she didn't look like she was wearing
makeup then either
what did miss hurt say to you during
that encounter
she was knocking on my door
to see if uh
i would take uh the house key her house
key to let the cleaning lady in
because she had to go somewhere
and i said i woke up that day and i had
some kind of chest cold thing i was
upstairs laying down and so i
looked at her and i said hey listen i'm
i
i'm feeling sick i'm going to be
upstairs laying down this entire time
for the day or whatever and that uh so i
can i'm not i can't do it
and then uh she stood there and
and uh is like
well i've got to figure out what to do
like maybe if she was only dependent
upon me to to give the housekeeper the
key
it's the same the housekeepers it cleans
both of our places
and uh
so i said hey listen won't you go ahead
and take the key and put it in an
envelope and bring it downstairs to the
concierge you know one of the and that's
where the key would be and tell hilda
who is the housekeeper that uh that's
where the key is
and uh that's it and here's your set and
she was like yeah okay i guess i could
do that and i'm looking i'm three feet
away from her two and a half three feet
away from my talking with
and how long did that conversation last
three minutes
did you see miss hurt again the next day
yes i did where did you see her
all right it does
i go down i'm leaving my apartment on
tuesday to go downstairs to the cafe to
go get something hot to drink i still
haven't shopped or did anything for
what's a chest cold
and uh so i wanted something hot to
drink i go downstairs
and uh as i'm locking my door
that uh all of a sudden a group of women
uh uh walk come up to penthouse three
because in the corridor on the graph you
could see we share the same corridor
so i closed i'm locking my door and
a group of women show up
did you recognize who the women were
three of them yeah who were it was you
know something i'm not sure if it was
four or five women but it's uh
amber
it's her sister whitney and it's uh
uh
melanie iglesias who's a makeup artist
for johnny and
amber
and then there's two other women i'm i'm
that i didn't i didn't recognize but
not sure did you interact with the women
at all
well i did
after closing the door whitney who calls
me her spirit animal came running came
running down the you know down the
the hallway going isaac spirit animal
and i'm
i'm going hey listen i'm not feeling so
hot i'm not feeling so good and i get
duck under arms you know stop and i love
you but stop and i duck on the rums and
and and i go past and i'm now passing
the other ladies
uh amber and her uh who she's with and
uh i'm i'm looking at them they're
laughing of this whole scene and then
that was it and then i walked one past
and went down and got some hot tea did
you see ms hurd's face during that
encounter it was a quick glance but
nothing's you know nothing's just
shot out to me to like notice anything
did you see miss hurt again the day
after that
well i saw again that day
oh can you describe that please yeah
that on the way back
from me being outside the cafe getting
having a tea i come walking back in and
now all her and her the women that she
was with are coming back out and we're
in the lobby
and so and the doors of the lobby it's
all windows is
great light shine through the entire
lobby
and the women aren't there's a table in
the middle of the lobby and her uh
her friends or
i don't know if they're friends or not i
know three you know one's a sister and
the other one's a friend they're coming
they're walking on one side of the table
and then she's on the other side of the
table where i'm walking and now
we're walking past each other
and she's you know of course we're going
to acknowledge each other in looking at
each other and now she's the sun shining
right in our face it's to my back
because i'm walking in and so
that's like this and
saying all right hey all right enjoy
yourself have a good time or whatever
whatever you're doing you know and go by
and i went up
and that was it that was the second time
that i saw her and that's on tuesday and
did you get a good look at her face
during that second encounter absolutely
the sun's shining right on her face
did you notice anything unusual about
her face nothing no no no
cuts no bruises no swelling no
red redness no it's amber it's amber's
face
and then did you see miss hurt again the
day after that yes it did
and that's wednesday may 25th that's
right
where did you see her
at that point it was like okay i gotta
shop for something to because uh
otherwise i'm not gonna get rid of this
chess code
i i'm gonna go to the store
and on the way back
in between the garage and the building
there's this
room with like vestibule you know that's
uh
that's you have to walk through
and
i'm coming in to go into the building
and amber and whitney her sister are
coming out of the building to go into
the garage and we met there
how long did you speak with them if at
all
yeah we spoke that's sold
what it we're facing each other
um bit them
amber and whitney
are
across from me we're two and a half feet
two feet away from each other talking of
course and so we stop of course to say
hey what's up what are you doing where
you going where you going where you
coming from
i have bags of food in my hand of the
stuff that i went and i bought
and so i said hey i'm coming from
shopping i finally bought myself some
stuff to get rid of this chess call
thing
and uh
they go and there's they're going to the
uh cvs
and they look at me and this and so
what's yapping
everything everyone's smiling and stuff
and
and she says you sure we can't get you
anything did how about we get you some
aspirin or some you know some
cold stuff i said no i think i got
everything
and uh that and they said you sure and i
said yeah yeah of course i got it done
so don't sweat it
and
uh
uh uh you know
a kiss or whatever i got my hands i
can't hug or whatever so
and then
uh
i was said to see you
and
i went and went up and they went through
the garage that was the
that was that was it that day did you
have a good look at her face during that
conversation yes this room
yes
yeah this room
it's comp it's it's completely lit
that it's a spot and there's a camera
taking uh uh uh
you know cameras always on the security
camera and all always and so it's got
good lighting and stuff because this is
a spot where if you use your fob key to
to go into this into the building well
the door takes a long time to you know
it's one of those things with the uh
pressure thing that the door just
doesn't close shut it takes a while to
for it to close someone could be in the
garage is not supposed to be in the
garage run and hold the door open
and that they then they get into the
apartment building and then who knows
some maybe somebody gets ripped off but
so it's well lit
for security reasons and that there's a
there's a camera there it's taking
pictures you know doing what the camera
does was misheard wearing makeup during
that um
discussion neither of them looked like
they were wearing makeup at all
whitney had this hat on that uh
it was a fun hat or whatever
uh and that
no it's no no makeup i don't i don't
even know whitney to to be a a makeup
person
and that uh
amber no she looked like she was you
know just natural
amber it's it's all you know just as
always no makeup did you notice any
marks on miss hurt's face
no
no did you notice any swelling no
no swelling no there's no nothing
there's no swelling no bruising no
redness no cuts no
i don't even
you know
nothing
turning back to may 21st for a second
when you first heard that ms heard
told you mr devitt hit her do you recall
that
say that again
when miss heard told you that mr depp
had hit her on may 22nd
yeah my birthday
how did you feel hearing her say that
all right
what's the relevance to how he feels
i mean it's a present sense impression
of how he perceived that in that moment
i'll sustain the objection
mr burch did you see miss heard at all
the rest of that week of may 23rd
no
did you learn at some point in time that
ms heard had filed for divorce from mr
depp
say that again
did you learn at some point in time that
ms heard had filed for divorce from mr
depp
yeah
how did you learn that
i learned it from the internet
after the weekend
around at probably monday
sun either sunday or monday
i'm on the internet and i end up
seeing a picture
of
it was the friday
of that
that week the past week
and there's a picture of amber
wearing a black morning dress and with
this brown mark
on her cheek
and that she's
out she's been to a divorce you know
she went to go file for divorce that's
how i found out were you surprised when
you saw that surprise is not the word
it's like what the hell is this what's
going on
at any point when you had seen her um
during that prior week had she told you
that she intended to file for divorce
i'll i'll allow it go ahead you can
answer the question sir
what's the question again
at any point when you had seen her
during that week
had miss heard told you that she
intended to file for divorce no no
never once
sunday monday tuesday wednesday and
thursday or friday not even see it no
there's no i'm clueless she does not she
did not say
anything about divorce
so what did you think when you saw those
pictures um and read the articles and
learned that she was filing for divorce
all right i'm sorry objection relevance
to what he thought
it builds on all the testimony he's
given previously i'll sustain the
objection
when did you see ms heard next after
that
she knocks on my door
june 3rd friday
friday a friday night june 3rd
she knocks i
she knocks on my door around 11 o'clock
is and is the next time that i see her
and what happened when she knocked down
your door on june 3rd
i opened the door i opened up the door
and naturally you know something i'll
say is hey how you doing you know
to say hello
so i opened up the door and said hey how
you doing and she looks at me and she
says not feeling so hot that uh i made
some food would you like to come over
and eat with me
and at that point after you know
everything i've seen i looked at i said
listen
me and you we're not going to talk
anymore after everything that i've just
seen all week long from from the past
the past week and change
uh listen i'm confused i'm angry and i'm
frustrated by everything that i've seen
and that i think the best thing is for
me and you that we don't talk anymore
did you say anything in response yes she
in response to that she looks at me and
she says i told johnny i don't want
anything
the lawyers are making me do all of this
and i
you know that's what she said
did you respond to miss her
no what i was thinking was that to me
when after saying that after she said
that to me i'm thinking to myself
hey
how did you know
i'll sustain that objection next
question
did you see any injuries on ms heard's
face on june 3rd when you spoke with her
no
did you ever speak with ms hurt again
after that
well she said to me
after
uh
that the
lawyers are making me do all of this
then
she's uh i was just looking at her and
then she ended what she was saying by
saying uh well i'm sorry you feel that
way
and i closed the door
and would never talk to her ever again
did you have any interactions with the
staff of the eastern columbia building
um
about miss herd's allegations uh against
mr deb objection your honor may we
approach it okay
mr brooch did you have any interactions
with the staff of the eastern columbia
building about miss herd's allegations
against mr depp
yes
and at some point
did you see a security video taken in
the eastern columbia building
yes
when was that
sometime in june
maybe two weeks in or something like
that it's two three weeks in
can you describe um what you saw in that
video yes i can
there was a video
of uh
amber and whitney
waiting uh at the elevator a mezzanine
level coming from the garage obviously
and uh waiting for the elevator
and
whitney
does this to amber
and hits her like faking hitting her in
the face going pow and then they start
laughing did ms heard react at all in
that video to the fake punch that you
observed whitney throw yeah she's
laughing after doing it they both uh you
know laughing at each other with each
other
mr brooch do you know who elon musk is
sure
have you ever seen mr musk in person
yeah
where did you see him in person
first time was uh
i'm getting into the elevator on the
rooftop
penthouse level i'm get going into the
elevator and he's coming out of the
elevator going past me
and when did that take place
this is after may this is sometimes
june it could be july but after may
in that same year 2016.
yeah
and when was the second time that you
saw mr musk
uh one morning waking up and going and
opening up the shades to
uh the bedroom and it's on the second
floor
and it overlooks the balconies our
joining balconies because
my balcony joins with uh john and
amber's of balcony
and that i
opening up the shades i see
uh elon musk going through
the balcony door on their side uh to
then walk down a common corridor
to that then at the end leads to a
door that you then you walk out to the
rest of of the rooftop
and could you go to the pool you go to
the gym and stuff so
i'm looking out and now the view the
the view out the window is of the both
of our balconies so that's where i saw
him and when was that
oh i sometimes it is either june july
some but it's after may
mr bruce how long have you known mr doug
met him i believe in 1980 and uh was 42
years
well it's going to be 42 years
have you ever seen uh mr depp be violent
when angry with miss hurt objection
leading
i love the question okay
i'm allowed to answer yes yes what's the
question again have you ever seen mr
depp be violent when angry with misheard
no
well the from what i said uh from before
there was an argument that i walked in
so there's obviously there's that that
but
have i ever seen him be violent to her
uh with uh physicality no did you ever
see him hit her never
in your three and a half years living at
the eastern columbia building next to mr
depam's heard did you ever observe any
injuries or marks on misheard objection
leading your honor all right i'll
sustain us to lead
did you ever notice anything unusual
about misheard when you were living at
the eastern columbia building objection
leading your honor i'll allow it
i can answer yes sir what's the question
again did you ever notice anything
unusual about miss heard during the time
that you were living next door to her at
the eastern columbia building besides
having great teeth no
mr burj are you appreciative of
everything that mr depp has done for you
objection your honor
leading and relevant
all right i'll sustain us deleting all
right
mr brooch how do you feel about what mr
depp has done for you objection
well you know what no i'll go ahead okay
go ahead i think that's what i think
that's withdrawn go ahead i can answer
the question
oh
you could just answer the question sir
and the question is how do you feel
about everything that mr depp has done
for you oh come on this is it's unreal
yeah it's you know
you think too much about it you're gonna
cry
that uh
i appreciate everything
that he's done
for me um
you know i
i it's like stuff you can't pay back
would you lie for him under oath no no
no no no no
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question
have you given truthful testimony today
sir objection your honor leading it's
still leading i'll sustain the objection
that's all i have okay thank you all
right cross-examination
let's start with the makeup
now you know that ms heard was just
excuse me
i didn't hear the beginning of what you
started saying i said let's start with
the makeup okay okay you're aware that
miss hart miss heard has both modeled
and been an actor and had been for many
years before you met her correct
i knew she acted i didn't know she was a
model okay
were you aware that she had a commercial
uh uh
agreement with l'oreal for example
when now well back then
what's your knowledge
i don't know any of that okay have you
ever been with miss heard
when she has put makeup on
i've been in the room yeah when she's
putting when makeup was getting put on
her yeah when makeup was being put on or
was this for
some acting role or something like that
it was an event that they were going to
so that was somebody else applying
makeup to ms heard who was going to have
some gala event that she was going to
yeah
okay have you ever been
with miss heard
in her
bathroom
or anything when she's applying her
makeup in the morning no okay
do you are you familiar with amica cream
what is it amica
amica yes no okay
do you know what type of foundation ms
heard uses
no do you know what type of concealer
ms heard uses
no do you know what type of tint
ms heard uses
that's no clue do you know what types of
powders ms heard uses
oh okay so
when you're saying that you didn't
notice any makeup would it be fair to
say
that
you
yourself are not familiar with what type
of makeup amber heard uses on a daily
basis
i don't know what she uses on a daily
basis that's my point now the first time
that you saw her which was may 22nd yeah
ms heard was there were you aware she
was on her way to somebody else's
birthday party not yours but somebody
else's that day
no okay
can you tell me what her hair style was
that day it's just down
down as in
just regular house she has it up now
she's got some kind of hair style but no
she's shoes no hair down regular no
makeup just hanging well when you say no
makeup you don't know she was not
wearing makeup correct
for a fact correct no
and you don't know whether she had
applied amica cream correct
no
and i didn't even know what amica cream
is and you don't know whether she had
had
applied concealer or foundation or
powder or tint correct that's correct
okay
now
if she's going out
to a party yeah do you think she would
want to have her bruise exposed
objection your honor
what's the objection calls for
speculation
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question so
do you recall what ms heard was wearing
that day
you know something i could have sworn
she had on a schmatta dress
a hippie dress at that particular time
but i could be confusing it with june
3rd she's got this victorian type of
uh
[Music]
long hippie dress
that has embroidery and i
she definitely was wearing that vet that
night
all right but but let's go back to may
22nd did you recall what she was wearing
i could have swore she was worn uh
wearing a another schmatta dress that
i've seen hanging around
the apartment with
and do you recall what color
no
okay
do you recall what jewelry
ms heard was wearing that day
no okay
now you indicated that there was a
security guard there and there was josh
drew
correct
and was there anyone else there yeah the
two locksmiths okay and also in the
apartment
for a fleeting second person went
walking by and who
seemed to me
looked like it was raquel pennington but
it could be
it could have been
uh another friend that was supposedly
staying with them
okay so you saw somebody come by so so
no go
go through
the living room and then
they're out of the picture because they
went upstairs so they're at this that's
somebody that else was in that room and
felt walking by okay yeah
so and you talked to josh what did josh
tell you
yeah that's true he took you to the side
what did he tell you objection your
honor hearsay
all right i'll sustain the objection to
hearsay
all right
before you spoke with josh drew in the
other room
what if anything had been said about
what
mr depp did
the night before
objection to the extended calls for here
say your honor all right yeah hearsay
objection i'll sustain that objection
but he already testified about what
amber said
i'll go back to that okay so what
exactly did amber heard tell you
happened the night before
as i was walking up the first time
she turned to me and said
johnny came by last night and got
violent
so i'm changing the locks
on
one penthouse one
three and five
don't worry about your place
okay
did you ask her for any more specifics
on what she meant by getting violent
huh did you ask her for any specifics
about what she meant by he came by and
got violent
no okay
okay well i'm going to jump you to the
next day for a few and then i'm going to
come back but let's go to the next day
so the next day you testified that you
saw her twice correct
from sunday no monday i saw once in the
morning uh
that's when she came by to ask if you
could have the key or that you could
leave the key for the house right for
helder and you weren't feeling well
right that's right okay so
you wouldn't have been standing very
close to amber right because you were
sick
well i opened up the door and i'm
holding the door we're like three feet
away from each other yeah okay and you
told her you were sick right
yeah okay do you know where she was
going out someplace correct
she had she was going somewhere right
she wasn't going to be there all right
do you know whether she had applied any
amica cream that morning to her face
no do you know whether she had applied
any concealer to her face that morning
no do you know whether she had applied
any foundation that morning
no do you know whether she had applied
any tint that morning no do you know
whether she had applied any powder that
morning no okay
now the next day i can't tell you she
looked like she wasn't wearing any
makeup right and would you agree that
people who are models and actors can be
pretty darn good with putting makeup on
so that you can't tell they're wearing
makeup objection your honor
foundation calls for speculation
i think that's a fair question to ask
him
i'll sustain as a speculation next next
question
do you have any knowledge of the skills
of amber heard with respect to putting
on makeup
well it can't be that good because she's
got a
friend who's is a makeup artist who came
over to do makeup but i don't really
know
right and and that makeup artist that
comes over does it when she's going to
be on some show or in some big public
event or gala right
yeah yeah that makeup person and you're
talking about melanie iglesias right
there yeah yeah exactly and that makeup
person doesn't put amber's makeup on
every day for her does she
i wouldn't know how many times have you
did you see melania glacis put makeup on
amber
one time okay it's just one time okay so
she wasn't living at amber's house right
no no no i had we i
hung out with her and uh husband and
johnny and uh and amber and you know
over there is a one-time eating
uh and then another time i was when i
met her that uh
seeing her do makeup for these guys okay
so so you don't
you're not saying that that amber
doesn't know how to put makeup on
herself
correct
oh no i'm sure she does okay
but again i would think she does
you know
but for the most i'll tell you what over
three and a half years
living
around around each other
for the most for the most part she's
not a makeup wearing person completely
natural ha
rocky
total great complexion texas
natural neck girl next door
no makeup wearing hanging out did amber
ever tell you she was not wearing makeup
did she ever tell me
in any of those three and a half years
that you're saying she wasn't wearing it
around the house did she ever say i
don't have a stitch of makeup on
as as many times as she's told me
i am wearing makeup which is i can't
remember so i don't know yeah no
i
there's not one time i remember that was
saying that okay so now let's go to the
next day i think that's the day you've
got the two times uh that you saw her
she's with other people yeah and she's
either going out or coming in correct
well first time they're coming in
and the second time they're going out so
they've been out someplace before
they're coming in correct
objection your honor
foundation
i'll allow it
you can answer the question sir oh
i have no clue
okay okay
but they're
they're physically
entering the house in other words they
haven't been in the house they're coming
to the house from someplace right oh i
would have no idea when i walked out who
knows they might have been out
in
twice
before that but i i don't know they
could be coming from another apartment
you know coming you know to go there and
i'm seeing them it could be the second
time that they're entering this
apartment or the first time or the third
time yeah i don't know okay i have no
idea and and
do you know so you don't know where they
were
no
no idea whether they were out in public
someplace correct
no of course not i won't know that all
right um and then the later time that
you saw them that day they were going
out is that correct
yeah okay okay
and do you know whether amber had any
amica cream on that day
i said no
i don't know and i'll try to make this
faster do you know whether amber was
wearing concealer foundation powder or
tint that day
i don't know okay
now the next day
i think you said it was she and whitney
is that correct
on wednesday yeah okay yeah yeah okay um
and again do you know whether she was
wearing any amica cream
sir if you could just dance
i'm totally sorry i'm sorry
that uh
no
and do you know whether she was wearing
concealer foundation powder or tent no
okay can you tell me what amber's
hairstyle was
on the 23rd
that's monday like i said when she
knocks on my door
hands down
okay
can you tell me what she was wearing
that day
not exactly but if i if best of my
recollection
pair of dungarees
and a t-shirt
okay at the time when she
knocked on my door
to give me the key
if she went home
to go change or something like that i
got no clue okay do you remember what
color the t-shirt was i think it might
have been white best of my recollection
do you remember what jewelry amber had
on
okay let's go to the next day the
wednesday and you've got all these
people here
next day is tuesday
okay next day tuesday is when you had
the bunch of people coming together to
her house the first time right right
what was she wearing then
you want to know something i do remember
uh
of a
women's
beige
long coat
kind of like a a woman's uh
not a raincoat but it could be similar
to that
it was a beige
long
kind of looking like a business coat
type of thing the female version of a
colombo jacket okay and what was she
wearing under it
oh
i have no i i
have no cloak okay and do you remember
what jewelry she was wearing
no okay now you said that on the 22nd
that you kissed her on the cheek what
day uh the 22nd your birthday 22nd
sunday yes okay so
when you showed it the first time you
went like this
right and then the next time when you
said you did the kisses you went like
this
what's your typical way of kissing women
when you greet them i think
i'm not
understanding any of what you just did
okay so when you
well i'll just leave it at amber when
you
i take it that you would regularly kiss
amber on the cheek when used to say
hello and to say oh yeah
yeah absolutely and tell us how you did
that
objective can you just show
us how you did that which time regularly
did you have a different way of kissing
her on the cheek different times or did
you have a general way that you would
greet or say goodbye to amber with
kisses regular it's a regular you know
you give a you give a peck on the cheek
goes you know like you just touch cheeks
and
okay that's that so it's it's a pretty
soft it's kind of like a almost a
superficial one or is it a really hard
one on the cheek
no
it's uh you know just uh yeah you kiss
someone on the side of the cheek i don't
know pressure wise what kind of torque
is there
uh i mean is it is it just one of these
little pecks or is it is it much harder
oh it's a regularly it's it's you you
touch you know you touch and point and
that's that
okay so so you think it was pretty hard
you you peck her on the cheek pretty
hard every time
objection your honor no i'll sustain an
injection if you want next question okay
you also showed that you did a one like
this did you ever do it at two kiss when
you greeted amber
two general i'm not european i'm from
brooklyn no that no you give you know
europeans do you know
both sides and sometimes you even three
bam bam bam
you know but you never did that
no no no all right let's go to the fake
punch i want to make sure that i
understand exactly what you remember
seeing yeah you said that it was two to
three weeks into june is that correct
that you saw it
it's got to be somewhere in that period
okay to some somewhere in the
the first three if the
i would say the first three weeks of
june
all right uh
yeah somewhere like that can you recall
which
week no okay so
you saw
whitney and amber was there anyone with
them no okay do you recall what either
of them was wearing
long jackets
yes actually i do okay long jackets you
know overcoats
and how was amber's hair styled that day
down
pull back
pulled back well when i say po you know
it's like hairs down
you know maybe because of something
around the neck or whatever
the pair is you know flipped back or
whatever not tied back i don't remember
if it was tie back but just where it's
full
full that i remember
okay so now where were they standing
when you watched this
this is uh the
where would they stand yes
they're standing waiting for one of the
elevators
on the mezzanine floor
where there's
i guess you could see if you're there's
cameras that
you know has that view of the
the the
of the elevators on the mezzanine floor
so they're on the mezzanine level yeah
this is the same level
this is the same level there's
apartments on that level
and that that's how the exit how you get
out to go to the garage
and so were they coming back from the
garage
well if they're standing at the elevator
outside
that it's could be
and waiting to get into the elevator on
that floor so it could be that
maybe they came from outside maybe they
know somebody
who lives on that floor because there's
apartments there i got no clue where
they're coming from this is that's not
even in the thought process when i see
that when i see
this
it's not like well i wonder where
they're coming from oh no it's just
so now what i saw tell me where they
were each standing
as i'm watching the video
this tape
uh amber's on the left
and whitney's on the right okay
and then
tell me just take us through tell me
what you saw
amber's on the amber's on the left
whitney's on the right they're hanging
out can i stand up yes sir
and so here's amber here's whitney and
they're hanging waiting for the elevator
and whitney does
looking at each other yapping or
whatever they're doing and
whitney goes like this
just a fake pow and then they both start
laughing and then they're just standing
there doing yapping doing what they're
doing and how close does whitney's fist
get to amber
oh i'm watching this it's a fake thing
it's not it's not like she went and she
hit her
you know it's just coming by
you know
fake punch going by
this you know that [ __ ] okay make him
believe
just make him believe it's a belief
punch
okay
and and then they both laugh you say
yeah they both you know they just
thought you know did you watch them get
on the elevator no
okay so the part that you saw they the
elevator never opened during that time
that's that's right okay that is correct
and how many seconds would you say or
minutes would you say
this little clip was
oh
what i saw was
10 seconds uh 15 seconds
okay and do you recall what day that was
that i saw this no no no
was there a date on this the video
oh i don't i don't uh i if there was it
wasn't something that i acknowledged
okay great do it thank you all right now
let's go back to the argument that you
witnessed between mr
uh depp and actually ms heard who was on
the phone or the speaker phone do you
recall testifying say this again start
against yes let's go back to you
testified that you observed an argument
between mr depp and ms heard do you
recall that you came into the room mr
dev had
amber on speaker phone do you recall
that yeah okay mr mr depp was drunk
would you agree
yeah okay and do you recall that amber
was actually in london not new york
no you don't recall that no i thought
it's it's i think i thought it was she
was in new york okay
and
you recall that mr depp was accusing
amber
of sleeping with somebody right
there was somebody else in the room with
her
and that's that's and
that's what they were arguing about
are you sure that mr dapp
wasn't
thinking there was someone in the room
and she was trying to tell him there
wasn't somebody in the room
he
uh
say that again
are you sure he wasn't
saying someone was in the room and she
was trying to convince him there wasn't
anybody in the room well he said that
that he heard uh the other voice
okay and were did you hear the voice oh
no i walked in there already it's this
is already
in motion right and amber's saying why
are you saying that
right
amber was amber was saying
come on baby why are you being like this
what do you do what are you doing come
on johnny what does this donate why are
you being like this right and it was
taunting
how is it taunting to say why are why
are you accusing me of having somebody
in my room
because they were in the midst of no
solution
at that point
it's
it would be
if instead of taunting saying listen
john let's talk tomorrow
and let's end this conversation right
now and every and
and we'll talk tomorrow and we'll get to
an understanding because there's not
going to be any solution right now but
there was none of that it was just con
continuous oh baby oh baby
so and that kept it going
if
if mr depp in his drunken state
was suffering from delusions
and
thought he heard a voice and wasn't do
you think it would have been reasonable
for amber to be saying what's going on
why are you saying this what's going on
objection your honor speculation
i'll allow the question if we can answer
it you can answer the question sir if
you
would i think it would be what
if if mr depp was suffering from
delusions
and there wasn't anybody in the room and
he hadn't heard a voice but thinks he's
hearing the voice would it be reasonable
for amber to be trying to figure out
what's going on
objection your honor hypothetical
speculation i'll sustain as a
speculation to that
question okay
and and the bottom line is you came in
on the call so you don't know
what he said first or whether there was
any voices correct
whether he
heard voices yes besides hers yes
no i didn't hear the beginning of the
conversation and then after
the hang up
he went straight to bed right
no after the first hang up
she calls back again
which
i was was was it necessary i don't know
and then a third knew
do you know whether she knew whether he
accidentally hung up or not
that he accidentally hung up right do
you know whether she knew whether
whether he hung up intentionally or no i
didn't say the same way that i wouldn't
know if like you know yeah she didn't
know that the telephone line got cut
right okay so so after the three calls
that you testified about he went
straight to bed right
went to the couch and laid down right
right and he was drunk yeah and went and
he went and went to sleep yeah he went
out do you know whether he'd taken any
drugs that night no okay
now
you have known you've already testified
you've known him for 42 years
he you didn't pay rent at the penthouse
correct
no no one did
right right okay and then after you
finished at the penthouse you went over
and lived with him in sweden correct
i live in uh one of his house uh house
that he owns
on suites and you still live there yes
and rent-free correct
yes okay and uh is it has other than the
hundred thousand you never paid that
back right the hundred thousand that
he's given you
no that's not that's a thing that
that's a thing
for me when i if the how i look at it
and stuff at some point i would love to
pay it back
pay back uh
some that money but that's not something
that is expected that he's expecting
would you say you're kind of beholden to
mr deb
no i'm not beholden at all
he's giving you a hundred thousand
dollars he's put you in that nice
i'm sorry i started i didn't hear the
whole question can you say it again you
were rent free in in penthouses for a
number of years and now you've been rent
free ever since in sweet sir
that's that's a nice friend yeah okay
and you're i think you testified already
you're pretty angry with ms heard right
when i wrote it down oh about all the
phony about the phony pictures that
would that were taken and put in uh
tabloids and about the fake narrative
and about uh
and the way she's uh trying uh at trying
to get a
a a a fraudulent dv claim to extort and
blackmail uh a man
yeah that kind of got me uh
uh pretty frustrated confused angry
upset yes which is why i said the best
thing for us to do is not to talk to
each other okay yes and was it fair to
say you're still angry with her
oh you know something it's six years
but we just heard am i angry anymore
i'm not you know
what i am is tired and i want this all
to end
how to go heal
him to go heal see you know
so many people are have been affected by
this malicious lie that she started and
she created and it's gone out the door
and around the world and so i don't i
can't even paint anymore i've stopped
painting for the last who knows how many
years and that's affected by stuff
it's it's it
i don't i i'm not angry at anybody i
want the best for her for her to take
her responsibility
heal
and and and and and
and move on
move on
and and for johnny john you know his
family has been completely wrecked by
all of this stuff and it's not it's it's
it's not
it's
not fair
it's not right
what ha what she did and what happened
for so many people to get
affected
from this
it's
it's insane and mr that's how this
happened and mr baroche if in fact
she's telling the truth and if in fact
mr depp
who has engaged in enormous rage and
domestic abuse and violence of amber
over a period of time that you wouldn't
know about
then maybe it's time for him to take
responsibility don't you think objection
your honor
what's appreciation speculation
[Music]
lack of foundation relevance
speculations
he just went off on this rant and rave
about assuming that she's you asked
questions i didn't ask a question that
launched that i'm going to sustain the
objection okay
i'll ask this mr brooch you don't know
whether mr depp has committed domestic
violence of amber heard do you
i never saw or witnessed
whatever type of claim
that is that is being said ever i've
never seen him be violent
since kit since teenagers from first
person i didn't ask you that i said you
don't know whether he has committed
domestic violence or abuse on ambergris
isn't that correct
that's correct i cannot witness
any
physical
violence but you have seen mr depp
use drugs as well as drink and be drunk
correct
oh yeah okay
now i've partaken
i'm going to ask you to take a look
let's let's pick up dep exhibit number
116 again it's already in if we can have
that published to the jury mr how how
much more do you think you have i i
think i can finish it up if you're
giving me five more minutes or maybe
maybe less okay all right
hold you to this okay okay
so mr bruce i just want to make sure
that i understand uh this is the
penthouse thing and you spread hope if
you could go to the microphone just hard
to hear yeah i just realized thank you
thank you
um
so on this diagram when you got out of
the l was
you said 9 30 today but in fact it was
between 9 30 and 10 that you came back
with your friend correct
no it was around 9 30. it could be five
minutes one way five minutes the other
way
could have been
just
do you recall saying it was between nine
and nine or between
9 30 and 10 earlier
today no that i said that do you recall
do you recall
are you sure it was 9 30 give or take
five minutes or could it have been
between 9 30 and 10
it was 9 30 give or take five minutes
five to ten minutes either way
and you saw a broken sconce
no i did not see a broken sconce
what did you see i saw a broken glass on
the floor shards of glass pieces of
glass which i figured
could have been a broken sconce
or possibly
maybe uh the
something from
uh the fire department stuff that's
around the walls
so it could be something broken from
that but i real you know uh maybe one of
the sconces broke i didn't see your
broken scots i just saw the glass okay
was was there typically a sconce right
there did you come off the elevator
yeah from my memory there was sconces on
on the walls certain places do you
remember looking that night and saying
where did this glass come from there's
there's a broken one did you tie it tie
it together
no wasn't it wasn't uh
it was and it's it was a
uh assumption it had to come from some
of those places because what the what
the glass looked like to me
looked like it might have come from one
of those places
could have been you know maybe the
stunts okay when you said from the fire
thing what were you talking about the
fire extinguisher no no no not the fire
extinguisher uh there's there was a uh
in the hallway that first hallway that
you go through the doors that you walked
through
after you get out of the elevator
those doors the fire doors
that you close all right hopefully no
one gets burned to death that would be
you know crazy
um
but then along the wall i believe before
by the staircase because there's a door
that's
when uh next to penthouse five then
there's the doorway the stairwell
uh door
and i believe there's a
thing that's by the floor there
that's uh
that's got a glass plastic thing
around it
so it could have been something from
that
approach all right yes ma'am
council
do you have another copy of the
deposition
is this something for me to look at
just wait for a question sir
i asked you a few minutes ago whether
you
you were sure that it was 9 30 give or
take five minutes or if it could have
been somewhere between 9 30 and 10 do
you recall me asking that question yeah
okay
and i'm going to ask you
to take a look
um
at page
39 do you recall giving your deposition
on november 20 2019.
oh from down in anaheim yes
yeah i remember that and were you
understood at that time
well that's yeah i think that's i
believe so yeah it was about two and a
half years ago wasn't it
two three yeah it's yeah like between
two and three years yeah sure all right
so if you could take a look starting on
page 39
and if you go to the line 21 where were
you on the evening of may 21 2016 and
your answer was all right so i was out
in the street i met i was with a buddy
of mine calls me he asked if i wanted to
go out and eat and i says i just ate
just meet me let's meet at the apartment
let's go hang out
so i met him at my apartment probably i
want to say around 9 30 or a little bit
later i don't know yeah between 9 30 and
10 do you see that
so i met him at my apartment probably i
want to say around 9 30 or a little bit
later
i don't know yeah
between 9 30 and 10.
and that ends up so does that refresh
your recollection that it could have
been a little bit is somewhere between 9
30 and 10
i'd go more with 9 30 give or take five
minutes because it could have been 9 20.
okay it could have been 9 25 it could
have been 9 35 but i go with 9 30. but
okay and did you see any police officers
no
okay did you ever hear any police
officers
no okay
so let's go back to this 116 for a
second
and you said that you saw a lot of wine
at right outside wait a second
line 115
sorry
uh the the exhibit that's in front of
you on the screen oh oh oh so you go by
penthouse now i have to hurry up to make
my promise to your honor um
so you see penthouse one there and you
said that the wine was in that area
right it's in front of the door
okay it's a little uh it's it's it's
it's going to be
a foot and a half two feet up further
north
north closer on the way to ph3 no it's
right in front of the doorway you have
it past the doorway the blue dot
[Music]
it's just in front of that doorway
okay can you put the dot exactly where
it was
okay can i move that down and how
how much how much wine was there
it was a puddle a puddle of wine could
could you walk past it without seeing it
no
it was and
could you tell a little bit about how
much
how much probably had been spilled of
the wine i mean were we talking like a
half a bottle a bottle uh looked like
you know a couple of glasses of uh
of wine
uh making a puddle
okay
it wasn't like a full bottle
that's
it's you know okay that's a bit more
okay thank you your honor i do have
another exhibit i need to put in and i
think that might take
a little bit longer than a couple of
minutes
how much time are you talking about well
i i can do it as fast as i can you can
try okay then let's can we pick heather
can you pick up well it's going to be
plaintiffs exhibit 548.
now
do you have a recollection of
mr depp
having a volatile relationship with his
earlier uh partner vanessa parody
no but then again i wasn't uh
i met her a couple of times i have no
i wasn't we weren't
our paths weren't crossing at that
particular time when they were together
all right do you recall mr depp ever
referring to
a circumstance with her as carnage
what's the relevance uh
we're talking he's trying to give
character testimony here and i'm
um i'll tell you what i'll move to a
different one all right now you said
that mr depp and ms heard were uh
um
you said that they were always nice to
each other
yeah
do you ever remember
mr depp referring to amber
with the term [ __ ]
like to a face
no no to you calling calling her a [ __ ]
to
you maybe in a maybe in a text uh
all right did did he do it more than
once
i would have i would have no
recollection of that i mean he's called
me a [ __ ] in uh in
in in a text so i mean it could be
i don't know how many
uh uh
texts if there's something specific if
you could show me a text that would be a
different story i don't but i don't you
know
we've had many texts together many kind
you know
okay let's go to line 57 then
it would be section 57 of the exhibit
that i have in front of me
now this is a text message between you
and mr depp do you see that
well this is 80 million taxes on it you
get under 50 go to the one that's number
57.
57 from
this is from me to him i'm sorry may i
approach okay sure
are you on 57 yet
57 right
and and this is
to you correct from mr depp
is that how it's uh this says from two
three two three four four five twenty
four hundred that used to be my
telephone number so that's two correct
oh okay i see i understand i understand
yes yes yes
all right and and the message she's
sending to you and this is october 18
2016 is hopefully that objection your
honor
exhibits not in evidence and she's
reading directly from it into the record
all right uh all right does this refresh
your recollection that mr depp referred
to
uh amber heard
as a content in fact
roger [ __ ] rotting corpse is
decomposing objection your honor sustain
the objection if you rephrase i'll ask
it i'll ask it differently
do you recall mr depp ever telling you
that he in base terms
[Music]
hoped that amber's writing corpse is
decomposing objection in the trunk of a
honda civic
a lot
i'm not understanding the question say
it again
do you recall mr depp
ever telling you that he hoped that
amber heard's rotting corpse is
decomposing in the [ __ ] trunk of a
honda civic
objection
i'll allow it yeah
you can answer the question sir yeah
that well i say yeah i'm seeing it here
so obviously yeah it was said
okay it was written
and then go to 59 please
and
when you had to move out of the
penthouse to go to sweet sir do you
recall mr depp
telling you
that uh
this was amber's fault and referring to
her
as a [ __ ]
can i read this thing first so that way
what's going on
so now the what's uh i've just read this
and i understand i remember i remember
this exactly because this is the period
of time you know i'm uh i'm moving uh
in that this
he's selling the apartments and there's
people who are coming over i'm still
living there and it would have been
better off
if uh
if uh i moved out so that way then the
real estate people can look at it and
not come in and look at the kind of
paintings that i make and all that kind
of scrap but my question to you is do
you recall
mr depp
calling amber heard a [ __ ] and saying
that it was her fault well it's written
there so
yeah i could see that okay so it's if
well i don't that's not what he says he
says that [ __ ] ruins such a [ __ ] cool
life we had for a while
i don't know it's that he says i can't
even look at the building anymore
correct right can't even look at the
building
right exactly okay thank you
i'd like to move the admission of those
two limited
excuse me
objection your honor there are some uh i
mean it's a significant exhibit there's
definitely some hearsay in there i think
i'll reserve on that on the entry of
that okay and we can discuss it later
time okay
are you done
i don't know
like my counselors
so are we done with cross yes
okay and redirect briefly um we're going
to be done with this witness before
lunch
okay there we go your honor okay
mr brooch do you recall that ms
bredehoff was just asking you some
questions about some text messages you
received from mr deb yeah
uh do you recall when those text
messages were sent
no i'd have to look at them again and
look at the date
could you display it to the witness
again
and i believe we looked at lines 59
excuse me 57.
do you see the date of when you receive
that text message
all right hang
on october november
is the month before it was the month
before i moved out
okay
when was that text message sent
it says uh 10 18 2016 that's october
that's i moved out the next month
so
in november
so this is from
october so was that message sent several
months after ms heard made um claims
against mr depp of uh domestic violence
oh yeah yeah
i'll allow it
yes of course this is after this this
whole fiasco that she started
and if we look at line 61
what am i looking six
what's the date on that message
it's 10 28 october
we can take that down
mr brooch ms brettahoff asked you a
series of questions about the security
video from the eastern columbia building
that you um observed do you recall that
yeah the powell
when did you understand that footage was
from
i'll sustain it asked an answer
did you have an understanding at the
time that you saw that video of when it
was from
your honor
question i'll sustain the objection
ms breth also asked you um a series of
questions about um the argument that you
overheard between ms hurd and mr depp on
the phone do you recall that yes
and you could hear um ms heard's voice
on that phone right yeah do you recall
if that was a facetime call or if it was
just regular speakerphone just this
speaker
and
what did you understand her tone to be
on that call that you overheard
i'll allow if you can answer that's fine
taunting egging on
almost demean demeanoring
the baby talk
to strike yeah i'll sustain the
objection as to his answer and i'll
strike it the whole answer you're on
that the answer yes
i believe you testified that mr depp um
hung up the phone during that
conversation do you recall that yes
did you understand that mr depp was
trying to end the argument by hanging up
the phone
his understanding of what mr depp was
trying to do all right i'll sustain it's
past speculation
he he he heard the phone call and he was
there to directly what johnny depp
intention was sustain rejection i know
what my interest certainly i'm sorry
okay thank you wait for the question
thank you sir
what was your understanding of um your
intent with respect to uh hanging up the
phone on that conversation he already
asked and answered when he said he hung
it up um and so it was asked and
answered i'll sustain the objection next
question nothing further all right is
this witness subject to recall
yes or no or not for you not from you
yes all right all right sir since you're
subject to recall that means that you
may be called again to testify at some
point so that means until that time the
rule and witnesses still
still is in place for you so you cannot
have any outside information or talk to
anybody about your testimony here today
and uh don't look at any information
about this on the news okay okay all
right thank you so you're free to go at
this time thank you thank you
all right so
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll go
ahead and take our afternoon
lunch we'll we'll give you until 2 30
to to take care of lunch again no
outside information and please don't
discuss this case okay all right thank
you have a good good lunch
all right so we'll come back at 2 30
then it's okay thank you
the parties we are going to be calling
brandon patterson by video deposition
designations at this point okay um and i
just wanted to alert the court how we've
handled the exhibits amongst the parties
we've met and conferred um the parties
have agreed that we have no objections
to the eastern columbia building
surveillance
videos that have been authenticated by
mr brandon patterson okay
um in his deposition okay do you what
exhibit numbers are they
or whose exhibits are they and what well
so
we have no objection to all i think
there's 87 currently so in the interest
of time for the jury and the court and
everyone here um because there are 87
we've agreed to show a selected smaller
set which had been identified by both
parties
and um both parties are taking on the
responsibility of introducing and
playing each exhibit for the jury okay
with your honors permission so since
mr depp is up now um in his case in
chief we are going to be playing the
video deposition of mr patterson
we will pause
the video
um and then when one of ms heard's
exhibits comes up no no
i'm sorry the deposition the person
just one time when that deposition were
just testimonies once
we understand that are you you're doing
then you're gonna pause right now and
then you're gonna do it i'm just
confused i'm sorry your honor let me be
a little bit more clear we're gonna
pause the video deposition
of of mr patterson to allow miss herd's
council to
publish okay the exhibit which is also a
video all right surveillance video i
know
it's gonna be a little difficult okay
right so we ask that the court perhaps
um remove the publishing from mr depp's
council's table and allow ms heard's
counsel to publish that exhibit which is
a surveillance video and play that okay
each side has taken responsibility of
the clips that they would like to play
yeah if that would happen but how many
times is this going to happen
how many do you have
yep
less than two minutes long okay and they
have uh
like 10 and again they're all relatively
short and what happened in the
deposition was that the witness saw the
video and then testified so you'll pause
it when he when the witness is watching
the video we're going to watch the video
okay all right and how long is this
video
i believe the entire deposition is about
an hour
one hour and 48 minutes one hour and 48
minutes and um with the exhibits i
anticipate it might take us till the end
of the day okay um but i nope no
promises
that's fine um i still need the exhibit
numbers
okay
if we could would you like to read them
into
i can read them
that that's fine if you just if you
would uh precursor with whose exhibit it
is so i have two lists so i just want to
make sure sure go ahead all right so
i'll give you i'll give you ours okay
um
it would be 670 670 671 671 672 672
that's right i'm sorry i'm going out
order here that was 666. that's okay 666
680
680 681
681 682 682
683 684
okay 685
686
687
688 six sixty eight
six ninety
six ninety one
six ninety two
six ninety three
six six nine
six nine four
six nine five
six nine six
seven
750 751
752
753
755
780 g
780r
780 x
789 a
789 b
789 g
789 h
789 l
789 n
789 r
974.
and
i believe we had 1041 which i think was
the
what actually came in from your uh today
the the um
the plans for the ecb i think that's the
same thing but it was 1041. and i'm not
sure if you're
objecting to that
no so 10 41. okay just one more so
you're entering all those into evidence
and there's no objection correct well
your honor i just want to confirm one
thing with council sure may i comply
right so just to confirm
convert okay
as long as they're all eastern columbia
surveillance videos your honor we have
no objections which they are which they
are so they're all interested except for
the plan which was that one i just
talked about okay so there those are all
entered into evidence then
all right and yes ma'am yours
and your honor just short circuit this
for the court um our eastern columbia
building surveillance videos are exhibit
numbers 250 through 336.
all right so exhibits 250 through 336.
that's no objection to those
exhibits correct
yes okay so
uh plaintiffs exhibits 250 through 336
are entered into evidence thank you your
honor um would would your honor like to
know the
10 exhibits that we were going to be
playing for the jury no that's okay
they're all in evidence that's all i
need to know we don't need to pull them
up so you're going to handle that yes
all right the only thing about this is
there's going to be duplicates i don't
know whether we want to try to sort that
they're in evidence so okay that's
that's
it's not gonna ring that bell that's
right
okay uh could you put the big tv up
though before we get the jury back in
just since it's gonna be a deposition
with testimony we're gonna go ahead and
put the big tv up so
if it works
[Music]
could you speak a little louder i'm
sorry
i thought the deposition video came
through the other screen i was just
i think it comes through here too
yeah oh it does okay
great yeah we will when you have a
remote witness the remote witness will
stay up there right and then you can use
those screens as well but when you're
using deposition we can still see it
over here fantastic we'll just publish
it to the big screen if you want to set
up before the jury comes out just to
make sure you have the person
let's just make sure it's all working
before we get the jury
all right seems like it's all working
okay
no though that's fine all right are we
ready for the jury then
okay
hmm
uh
all right
thank you ladies and gentlemen all right
your next witness
thank you your honor plaintiffs call
brandon patterson he is the corporate
designee of the eastern columbia
building by deposition designations all
right
patterson
all right ladies and gentlemen this is
the first one that we have
of of a few um where they already have
been uh deposed
and so you're going to see them on a
recording okay
no volume
do you have an audio connection attached
to
try it one more time
could you push play one more time
general manager
for what
uh if you could please state your name
and address for the record
sure brandon patterson 849 south
broadway los angeles california 90014
and if you could please state your
occupation
general manager
for what
uh i'm the general manager for the
eastern columbia hoa in los angeles
and how long have you been in that
position
i've been here at the building six years
okay were you there in 2016
yes
um and are you here under a subpoena as
the corporate designee for action
property management
yes
okay and if you could please pull up
exhibit one and just scroll to page 15
of the pdf please
does this look like a copy of the of the
subpoena that you received
um
yes
is it okay if i call your building ecb
yes
uh is it your understanding that ecb has
produced these three categories
of documents
and films
yes
please go to exhibit two and scroll to
page eight
and does this look like the topics of
the
of the deposition of a subpoena for
testimony
okay
um is it your understanding that uh
you're the most knowledgeable person on
these topics
i am the most knowledgeable within
action property management as it relates
to these items
are you responsible for for managing any
of the
records or managing preserving
any of the records and videos at action
property management
uh specifically as it relates to eastern
columbia
this is the only
property and building for action that i
manage
um
so action as a whole i i can't speak for
that but as as for ecb yes
thanks and this whole this whole
deposition i'll be just referring to uh
ecb related to action property
management
um
what was your role in locating the
videos responsive to the subpoen
to the to the subpoena
uh the videos had been saved um
from the original case um i don't recall
the exact year that was i think this is
number four now
um
so i
provided the video that was requested
that had been saved as the only videos
um
that were
that were requested and saved
and um who who saved them was that you
or someone at action property management
um i had initially worked on saving them
when i received the first list
and i guess i'm i'm
i don't know if you're referring to
the first set of videos that was ever
requested or subsequent
subpoenas i guess as this refers to that
were already saved and i just
transferred the already saved documents
so we'll get into
into more details um but
when was the first time you saved resp
um
security footage relating to
ecb
in response to a subpoena
like i said i don't recall the exact
year
it was the first case
between deaf and heard
as a response to subpoenas that we had
received from both parties
and what what was your role in
preserving those videos from from that
first time until now
can you expand on what you mean by
preserving
sure
did
uh
were these videos kept
securely in the same format
that
and were you responsible for making sure
that they were kept securely and in the
same format at ecb
yes um
how many cameras are there
at ecb in in 2016
um
i don't recall the exact number we've
since switched out the entire system
um and expanded on it i believe we
doubled the
cameras
which we currently have 40 44 so
i would be speculating but i think it's
probably around 2022 or so
originally
where in 2016 were the cameras
positioned
throughout the common areas
and did did ecb
take them as a matter of course sort of
all day 24 hours a day
uh the recordings were 24 7.
um
the concierge staff
periodically does review them
just as part of their daily duties
but the video footage is recorded onto a
dvr
in a
back then i believe it was like a 20-day
period before it was written over
is it correct that you're not
represented by an attorney i am not
uh did you review any documents or
videos before the deposition
i did not
have you ever communicated with mr
depp's former attorney mr weldman
uh yes
and did mr weldman do you know if he
drafted a decoration for you
in 2016
yes
is action property management
i believe you said this earlier is it
the property management company for ecb
yes
is he understanding that in 2016 deaf
owned the top floor penthouses in ecb
penthouses one through five yes
and are you aware of whether amber kurd
was a resident at ecb in 2016
yes
how many times have you seen
amber heard
personally
maybe
i mean i would be guessing my best guess
would be maybe
half a dozen to a dozen times
do you remember when those times were
like what year
i don't recall the exact year but likely
2016.
um
so moving to may 21st of 2016
uh are you aware that officers were
called to the penthouse of ecb
on that day
yes i am aware
were you there the day that the officers
were called to ecb in may of 2016. i was
not at the building when officers were
called
do you have any firsthand knowledge of
of
uh
why the officers were called
on may 21st 2016.
firsthand no i do not
you see amber at all on may 21st
uh not that i recall
did you see amber on may 22nd
2016
um not that i recall
did you see amber on may 23rd 2016.
um the timeline is 2016. i i don't
recall the specifics of those dates
specifically
can you say
can you testify to whether you you saw
amber heard it all the week of may 21
2016 personally
uh
not i don't recall the dates now
did you personally interact with mr depp
at ecb in 2016
no i never did
have you seen mr depp on video footage
in 2016
yes
you could please bring up um
exhibit 3 please
how would you describe mr depp's
behavior in that video
i would describe it as animated
and do you have any
in the times that you've seen mr depp at
ecb did you ever observe mr depp in an
animated
manner like you saw on the video
i do recall a video of mr depp in the
elevator
i guess in an animated state
and was that in 2016
yes
and do you have any familiarity with um
have you ever seen mr depp
appear angry in the times you've seen
him
at ecb
i wouldn't say
angry i use the term animated
and what does it turn animated mean to
you
what i saw on the video
when were you first mr patterson when
were you first contacted for video
footage after the may 21st police
call to the building
i don't
recall the exact
time frame
do you remember who contacted you
about the
may 2016 video footage
who first contacted you
i do not recall
know who selected what copy to preserve
and what copies
what to preserve
the attorneys from both sides
uh submitted a list of
video times and dates to be preserved
and do you remember uh
what times and dates those were
roughly
uh i
i don't have a time frame now
do you have a rough time frame of what
what the videos
that were preserved what times those
cover
um
my reflect recollection is that
may 2016 time frame
was it after the may 21st
incident that time frame
yes
um and do you know what role mr depp's
lawyers played in the selection process
the attorneys came to
uh the office here
uh set up
a viewing
area
reviewed video footage took notes
based on that review
um
and those
dates and times were provided to
retrieve the video and saved
and remember which attorneys came
either their names or who they were
to came to review the footage
i don't recall there's attorneys from
both sides that came
very close together and
i don't recall
who
who or what side they were on
and was all of the footage that they
selected preserved
yes
and were all of those videos that were
preserved taken in the ordinary course
of ecb's
business
operations
can you rephrase that
sure it's it's it's ordinary is it not
for ecb to have these cameras
rolling and the videos that were
preserved
were from those cameras that were
rolling in the ordinary course of
business
yes
and
do you know how many video clips um
ecb preserved
pursuant to the their requests from
attorneys
uh i don't recall the exact number it
was whatever was on the subpoena we
provided exactly what was on there
does the number 87 ring a bill
for how many
yes
uh and and do you know where the videos
were maintained
from 2016 until today
uh they were on a
a
portable drive here in my office
at ecb
yes
and uh how are they maintained it was on
a
portable
hard drive
and as far as you know are that is that
in the same condition that it was in
2016
to my knowledge yes
and uh where
were the 87 videos preserved on three
dvd discs or in some other
format
so through the subpoenas there the
videos were provided um to the different
teams
um i vaguely remember
cds um
they weren't stored on cds for purposes
here
i just have the portable hard drive
any more video footage other than those
87
clips
that has been preserved
no
and what happened
to any other video footage
that was not preserved
like i had mentioned earlier the ddr has
a capacity of so many days and it
rewrites over itself
and um
just for clarity how did you want to
make it clear how did you decide what
may 2016 video to preserve
the only videos that were preserved were
the ones called out via the subpoena by
the various
uh law firms or the two law firms
and do you know why there's no footage
from may 23 2016.
i do not
and you mentioned that both sides
requested preservation of the
video footage is that is that right
yes correct
um is he understanding that the press at
some point became interested in getting
statements from ecb relating to the may
21st incident
yes
uh did the press ask ecb or its
employees turn for statements
yes
and uh
what's the policy of
apm or ecb
with respect to press statements about
residents
the policy is that we do not give
statements to press
and
did amber ever ask you about that
yes she did
in 2016 uh do you know if
rocky pennington and josh drew
lived in one of the penthouses at ecb
yes
and did he ever see rocky with amber
yes
if we could pull up exhibit four please
uh mr patterson does this refresh your
recollection about which penthouse uh
rocky pennington lived in
yes
mr mr uh patterson i'd like to
go to the video footage now and go
through some video footage um
and let's start with exhibit five please
in particular around time stamp 18
55
19.
okay
all right we'll do that
so
oh
do
okay
mr patterson do you recognize this this
area
yes
um
and where is it
this is the
mezzanine vestibule between the building
and their own garage
and do you know if you
or someone else at ecb was responsible
for pulling this security footage and
keeping it
at ecb
i did pull some video early on however
the task was very overwhelming and took
away from my daily duties
um so the task was
sent off to an outside party
to pull all the videos based on the
subpoena list
and what was the outside party's name
i
i don't recall off hand
but it was it at was it at the direction
of you or acv
yes
um to assist you with time or
is that why
yes i did not have the time to go
through all of the video footage to
record it
do the ecb video cameras
have time and date stamps as a matter of
course
yes
and
in your experience are those time and
date stamps
relatively accurate
relatively accurate yes
and did you recognize the men in that
exhibit
can you replay it please
sure
and while we're waiting for the men
to appear
uh
how would you describe the the quality
of this vid these videos
compared to our
new updated cameras um
not as clear
and can can you be more specific about
not clear
would you consider these to be grainy
i would say this video here in the
paused state does appear to be somewhat
grainy
and does it appear to be
just a little bit blurry
yes this video as i see it now looks a
little blurry
did you recognize the men in this
video clip yes i do recognize mr depp
um
the first gentleman
looks familiar i can't place him at the
moment um
and
you have any reason to believe that that
that the date and time stamp are not
accurate
it does seem consistent with the time
stamping
of the video so unless it was
somehow altered
i would say it appears to be accurate
and the video camera that you preserved
in your office at ecb since 2016 has not
been altered is that correct
correct let's go to exhibit six please
you recognize where this is
yes
and where is it
this is the
uh mezzanine level again um
vestibule the mail room is directly
behind it uh leading to the elevator
vessel fuel
and does that look like it accurately
portrays the scene
this shot accurately depicts the area
correct
and do you recognize those men
as i previously stated i do recognize mr
death
the other ones i do not
and did the date and time stamp look
accurate
yes
um if we could please go to exhibit
seven
okay
all right
thank
you sir
do
um
rip switch back okay
and do you recognize uh where this is mr
patterson
uh yes i do okay and does that look like
a clip from um
the surveillance video in the elevator
at ecb
yes
and does it accurately portray the scene
when i i don't know what you mean by
scene
does it look like ecb like the elevator
or dcb
yes
and is this is the quality of this a
little bit grainy as well
as it's displayed right now yes
um and do the time the date and time
stamps look accurate like ecb keeps in
the regular course of business
yes
and um
could we please play the
video so we can see who's getting on
and you recognize those people getting
on the elevator
mr pattinson
yes i do recognize mr deb
and uh is smoking permitted on elevators
at ecb
no it's not
let's move exhibit eight please
do you recognize this this uh as ecb
video footage
yes and you recognize the men on the
elevator
as i previously mentioned uh mr dad told
me
and
um do those dayton timestamps look
accurate
yes
how would you describe mr depp's
movements on this elevator
i'll use the
description animated again
is that he also swaying from side to
side
does this footage generally look like
the footage that that you preserved from
2016
yes
let's move
this
okay
and you recognize this area
yes
what is what what is it
this is the same shot that was
previously shown
the
mezzanine
vestibule
and is it shot from one of the ecb
surveillance cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the ones
that was preserved since 2016
yes
um
and do the dayton time stamps look
accurate as far as you know yes
um and were you responsible for pulling
this security footage generally
genuinely yes
and do you recognize the people in that
video
excuse me i do recognize mr dad
and what's mr depp holding
appears to be a jacket
and how would you describe how he's
holding it
with his left hand
and if we could please move to exhibit
11.
and do you recognize this is ecb
surveillance footage
yes
and where was that footage taken
uh this is back in the mezzanine
vestibule uh between the building and
the garage
say the last part just to be away
between the building and the garage
and was just one of the videos that was
preserved since 2016 by ecb
i don't recall this specific
clip but yes this
this is video that was preserved
and did the date and time stamps look
accurate like they would be on ecb
footage actually
do you recognize those people
uh i reckon recognize
and does mr depp appear to be leaving
the building that would be the pathway
from the building into the garage
and does this look like
true and accurate footage from the ecb
video surveillance preserve since 2016.
yes
moving right along to exhibit 12 please
and where is this video mr patterson
this video is the call box at the lobby
entrance on broadway
and do you recognize that as security
footage from one of the ecb
surveillance cameras that's been
preserved since 2016.
yes
and did the date and time stamp look
accurate to you
yes
can move to exhibit 13 please
and you reckon
thank you
uh where this is
yes
where
uh this is in the main lobby
of the building
and does that look like a surveillance
clip from one of the ecb surveillance
cameras that's been preserved since 2016
yes
and uh it says may 21st 2016 at 20
53 does that look like an accurate date
and time stamp from the ecb footage yes
and that looks like a true and accurate
copy of the surveillance has been
preserved
yes moving to exhibit 14 please
okay
um
you recognize this clip
yes and does it look like it's from one
of ecb security footage cameras that's
been preserved since 2016
yes
and where was this footage taken
uh this is the shot of the front desk
and would you agree that the footage is
also a little bit grainy
as it is displayed now yes
um
and do the date and time stamps look
accurate
um to you
yes
and do you recognize this as uh
surveillance footage from one of the ecb
cameras that's been preserved since 2016
yes
um do you recognize
either of the officers
i recognize them as officers
um and
does the date and time stamp look
accurate as far as you know
yes
move to exhibit 16 please
does this also appear to be a um acb
surveillance camera
footage
yes
and you recognize the per that person
who just
left the elevator
i do not
um
and
does this generally appear to be one of
the ones that have been preserved since
2016 at ecb
yes
and as far as you know does the date and
time stamp book accurate
yes
and for all of these
clips that you've seen they look like do
they appear to you to be true and
accurate
copies of the footage that have been
preserved
these seem very
grainy and slow to me um
from what i remember
but this these are
taken from eastern columbia video
cameras during this time
and preserved since that time at ecb
correct
and they were preserved in the same
condition
yes
can we please pull up at 17.
do you recognize this as a clip uh from
one of the ecb surveillance cameras
that's been preserved since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know as the date and
time stand to accurate
yes
and does that accurately portray the the
elevator scenes
at ecb
yes
um and can we move to exhibit 18 please
but do you recognize
this is ecb uh security footage that's
been preserved at easp since 2016.
yes
and it looks like an accurate uh copy of
what was preserved
as far as you know
as far as i know yes
and the date and time stamp as far as
you know look accurate
yes
please move to exhibit 19.
and mr patterson do you know whether or
not any of these uh time stamps are a
few seconds off here or there or not
do you believe there
is a
few second time discrepancy
and you know what do you know why there
would be a few second time discrepancy
or
i don't know the reason behind it now
okay
um
and
um did you recognize that video clip as
one of the videos that has been
preserved at ecb since 2016
yes
and and does that appear to be an
accurate copy of one of the surveillance
copies that have been preserved
yes
and as far as you know that the date and
time stamp is is reasonably accurate you
know with a couple seconds
uh margin
yes
then please move to exhibit 20.
and you recognize this as one of the
videos that have been uh
taken at ecb
want to buy a surveillance camera at ecb
yes
and is the are these one of the videos
that have been preserved by ecb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know
within a few seconds is the date and
time stamp accurate
as far as i know yes
and those appear to be two officers
leaving the
leaving ecb
yes
and move to exhibit 21 please
do you recognize where this is
yes
and what does it look like to you
uh this is the same shot from the kiosk
camera outside of the lobby on broadway
is it shot from one of the surveillance
cameras at ecb
yes
and does that appear to be one of the
clips that's that has been preserved by
ecb since 2016
yes
and as far as you know there's a date
and time stamp accurate as far as you
know
yes
exhibit 22
can we move to that please
does this appear to be uh
this clip appear to be taken one of the
ecb security cameras
yes
and which camera
uh this is the lobby
one of the lobby cameras
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was preserved at ecb since
2016
yes
um
and the as far as you know is the date
and time stamp uh accurate
yes within a few seconds
and were those two officers walking in
in in this video
yes does it appear to be two officers
or does this look like how the lobby
does it look like um
how the lobby
looks in the videos surveillance
preserved by ecb
yes
let's move to exhibit 23 do you
recognize this as video footage taken
from one of the ecb
security cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that's been preserved by ecb uh
since 2016
yes
uh and as far as you know are the date
and time stamps accurate within a few
seconds
yes
and do those appear to be officers
talking to the concierge
yes
and move to exhibit 24 please
and you recognize this as a video
footage taken by one of the ecb security
cameras
yes
and was this one of the clips that were
taken by ecb and preserve since 2016
yes um and uh as far as you know within
a few seconds are the date and time
stamped accurate
yes
can we please go to exhibit 27
and do you recognize this
um
okay
was one of the videos
from the ecb security footage that have
been preserved since 2016 by ecb
yes
uh as far as you know as a date and time
stamp accurate within a few seconds
false forex purpose uh and move to 28
exhibit 28 please
do you recognize this video as one of
the ecb surveillance videos
yes
uh and which which which surveillance
video
which which part of the building
uh this is the
okay does lobby
appear to be one of the clips that has
been taken and preserved by ecb since
2016
yes
as far as you know are the date and time
stamps accurate within a few seconds
yes
and um do those look like two officers
in the lobby to you
yes
move to 29
and you recognize this
video is taken from one of the ecb
security cameras
yes
and was this one of the
clips that have been taken and preserved
by ecb since 2016
yes
um and as far as you know is the date
and time stamp accurate within a few
seconds
yes
i mean this appears to be an accurate
copy of what was preserved
yes and move to exhibit 30 please
and you recognize this as
footage taken from one of the ecb
security cameras
yes
and it does appear to be one of the
clips that has been taken and preserved
by ecb since 2016
yes
um and that appears to be an accurate
copy of what was preserved
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
may we please go to exhibit 30.
and do you recognize this as one of the
video clips from ecb
video surveillance
uh yes
and is this the elevator
camera
one up yes
and do you recognize who's on the
elevator
uh it appears to be amber
and um does this look like one of
the
video
uh
clips that have been taken and preserved
by ecb since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know within a few
seconds is the date and time stamp
accurate
yes
can we please move to exhibit 30.
31.
and does this appear to be one of the
video clips taken from the ecb security
footage
yes
um and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken to preserve by ecb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know are the date and
time stamps accurate within a few
seconds yes
and while we're waiting for someone to
appear do you recognize the person at
the front desk if you can see him
and do you recognize who's walking into
the video now
i do recognize that as amber i'm
trying to get a
face a facial uh
recognition of the person up it has
can you see him now
yes
and who's that
his name is cornelius
do you know why mr harold and amber
would be going around that corner
uh the package room is around the corner
[Music]
and does this look like one of the video
clips that's been preserved and taken by
ecb since 2016.
yes
and does the date and time stamp look
accurate as within a few seconds as far
as you know
yes and does this look an accurate clip
from
the ecb footage
yes
i'd like to move this
in as exhibit 31.
uh and move to exhibit 32 please
and do you recognize uh
who's walking through the picture in
this video
yes
who is it
amber bird
and does this look like a video clip
taken from one of the ecb surveillance
cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the
videos that was taken and preserved by
acb since 2016
yes and as far as you know are the date
and time stamps accurate within a few
seconds yes
um
i'd like to move to exhibit 33 please
and does this look like uh video footage
taken from one of the ecb
surveillance cameras
yes
and this is does this look like one of
the clips taken and preserved by ecb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know are the date and
time stamps accurate within a few
seconds
yes
i'd like to move to admit this as
exhibit 33
and do you recognize who's in this video
right now
yes
who is it
amber heard
and where is she
this is the service corridor outside of
the package
okay and if we could please rewind the
tape a little bit and see who amber was
with
do you recognize that person
yes that's cornelius
and what's his last name
and was he walking out where was he
where was he walking out from
the package
where is this in ecb
this is on the main level service
corridor
and would you agree with me that this
footage is also a little bit grainy yes
i think the police i'd like to move to
admit exhibit 33
and if we could please move to exhibit
34.
and you recognize this as one of the ecb
security
camera
footage clips
yes
and this appear to be one of the
video footage clips taken and preserved
by ecb since 2016.
yes
as far as you know is the date and time
stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
and do you recognize who's in this
video
it appears to be amber
heard and do you know where this video
is
can you expand on that
sure is it an elevator
an ecb
um
and can we go back to that exhibit
please just for a minute
and can we go to roughly time stamp 18
22 26.
would you agree with me that the video
footage here is a little bit grainy
yes
and does it look a little bit fuzzy to
you
yes
and can we please move to exhibit 35
and does this look like uh video footage
from one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken to preserve by ecb
since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know did the time
stamps look accurate within a few
seconds
yes
if we could please move to timestamp see
18 41
29
and do you recognize who just walked in
the elevator
uh it appears to be amber i'm not sure
who the gentleman is
does that video appear a little bit
grainy to you
as it's displayed now
um and if we could please move to
exhibit
i think we're on 36
and is it
does this appear to be footage from one
of the security cameras at ecb
yes
and who who just walked through the
footage
uh amber hurd and
a gentleman
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb since 2016
yes
as far as you know uh is the date stamp
and time reasonably accurate within a
few seconds
yes
and would you agree with me that also is
a little bit grainy in that footage
yes as it's displayed now
um if we could please move to exhibit 37
and does this appear to be a video
camera from one of ecb's video
cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecd since uh
2016 yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
and did you recognize who walked through
that
video
amber hurt and a unknown gentleman
and is this video also a little bit
grainy as it appears
as it appears now yes
um i'd like to move in exhibit 37.
and please move to exhibit 38.
and is this appear to be video taken
from one of the security cameras at ecb
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb
since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a reason
within a few seconds
yes
uh and if we could see
go to
2256 please a time stamp wise
and you recognize who who's getting on
the elevator
i cannot see her face but it appears to
be amber heard
i move to admit this is 38 and then we
can move to uh
39 please
does this look like a true and
accurate copy of
or surveillance
footage from one of the ecg cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the clips
that was taken and preserved in 2016 by
ecb
yes
and when i say by ecb i i mean either
you or someone under your direction like
the contractor you
spoke of is that your understanding
yes
um and i'd like to move this in as
exhibit 38 i'm sorry 39 please
um
and if
and do you know who is working behind
the desk in this video
yes
and who's that
alex romero
okay can we move to uh exhibit
40 please
and does this appear to be a cl a video
from one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb since 2016
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
i'd like to move this in as exhibit 40
please
and if we could go to timestamp 21 1733
please
and if we could move oh yeah thanks
and you recognize who's getting on the
elevator
yes
and who is it
uh amber rocky and her sister whitney
and um
would you agree with me that the
video footage is a little bit grainy in
this
is it
yes has this displayed at the moment
um and does that date and time stamp
look accurate within a few seconds as
far as you know
yes
and does that appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb since 2016
yes
i'd like to move to admit that it is
exhibit 40 please
uh and move to uh 41 please
counsel could you pause it for a moment
let's just go ahead and
all right please jim let's go ahead and
take a 15 minute break till 4 o'clock
okay
all right thank you
all right we'll come back at four
o'clock then okay
all right we're ready for the jury then
okay
we're ready
um
all right
so
all right now you may continue thank you
and it does also look like one of the
clips taken from one of the ecb security
cam cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb since 2016
yes
and would you agree with me uh that the
quality is also grainy as it appears
in this video
actually as far as you know is the date
and time stamp look accurate uh within a
few seconds
yes
and you recognize the
people in this video
yes
and who are they
uh amber rocky and whitney
and move to 42.
and does this appear to be one of the
video cameras from ecb security footage
yes
uh does this appear to be one of the
videos taken and preserved by ecb since
2016.
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp
accurate within a few seconds
yes
and if we could please
see
go to 11
32
11 35
do you recognize this as a clip from
2016
one of the ones that was taken and
preserved by ecb
yes
and as far as you know the date and time
stamp is it accurate within a few
seconds
yes
uh move to admit this is exhibit 42
please and move to let's move to exhibit
sorry 42 and move to exhibit 43 please
does this look like footage from one of
the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this appear to be one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb from uh to since 2016
yes
as far as you know is the date and time
stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
and can you tell me where this is
or do you remember where that was
in the
building
that is the
mezzanine vestibule between the building
and the garage
okay
um and if we can move to exhibit 44
please
so
and does this look like one of the
videos taken from one of the ecd
security cameras
yes
um does this look like one of the clips
that was taken and preserved by ecb
since 2016
yes
uh and as far as you know is the date
and time stand back within a few seconds
yes
and do you recognize who's in the
photo
i mean who's in the video
uh it appears to be amber and trinity
esparza
trinity webb
trinity esparza
um and can you rewind that footage
please
um
and
does miss does does uh amber heard have
a sister
yes
do you know if that's amber heard sister
versus amber heard
could you tell
in this video
uh not a hundred percent now
um and would you agree that the videos
is also a little bit fuzzy in this clip
as it appears now yeah it's uh
grainy
um does this look like an accurate clip
um taken and preserved by ecb since
2016.
yes
um and if we could please move to
exhibit 46.
as far as you know did uh ecb
uh preserve all the footage that uh
mr depp's attorneys or and ambassador
attorneys
asked you to preserve
yes
and did you from your understanding do
you understand that the attorneys
some attorneys came and actually were
involved in the selection process of
videos
ecb in may of 2016. yes
um and moving to this exhibit uh
45 does this appear to be a a
video clip from a
from a
one of the elevator surveillance cameras
in ecb
yes and does this appear to be one of
the clips that was taken and preserved
by acb since 2016
yes
and as far as you know is a date and
time stamps accurate within a few
seconds
yes
um and i'd like to move to memphis's
exhibit uh 45
and or 46. um
and do you recognize the people in this
uh it appears to be amber and rocky
and would you agree that the footage is
a little bit fuzzy
yes as it's displayed now
um
i'd like to move to admit that it's
exhibit 46 and move on to exhibit 47
please
and does this appear to be a video clip
from one of the ecb security cameras
yes
does this appear to be one of the clips
taken and preserved by acb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know is the time and
date stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
would you agree that video footage is a
little bit fuzzy in this clip as well
yeah it says it's displayed and
this looks like one of the clips that
was taken and preserved by ecb since
2016
yes
um and as far as you know the date and
time stamp look accurate within a few
seconds
yes i believe we're on exhibit 48
um
does this appear to be a clip from one
of the ecb video cameras
yes
and this appears to be one of the
exceptions taken and preserved by acv
since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know are the date and
time stamps accurate within a few
seconds
yes
and do you recognize the woman who's
uh about to get on the elevator getting
on
uh which it looks like
amber's waiting to get on rocky just
came in and whitney's over the corner i
don't i don't know the other two
and can you
is would you agree that this footage is
also a little bit fuzzy
yeah it says it's displayed now
and that looks like an accurate clip uh
from one of the ones that was taken and
preserved by ecb since 2016
yes if we could please pull up exhibit
49 mr patterson are you familiar with
the layout at the
penthouse level of eastern columbia
building
yes
and uh
this is exhibit 49 that i'm showing you
and uh
does this look like
what you uh understand the layout to be
of the penthouse three first level does
this look to you like
what your understanding is of the layout
of penthouse 3 the first level
yes
and if we could scroll down please
does that look like the layout of the
second level
of penthouse 3
yes
move to admit exhibit 49 please and coin
please move to exhibit 50.
do
uh and could we zoom in a little bit
please
mr patterson do you recognize this as uh
the layout of
the penthouse level
uh nothing's labeled um
generally i guess
does it that look like the pool's in the
right spot on that exhibit
uh
yes
and
does does
from what you can tell does everything
else look as you would expect the layout
to be in your familiarity with the
layout in your experience
uh yes generally going back to the video
clips and we can walk there's a couple
i'm saving today to the end to see if
there's time um
uh but for the ones that i've show
for the ones that i've showed you
um
is your understanding that those are all
accurate copies of ecb footage that were
taken and preserved by acv since 2015
uh yes
and
again by by taken by ecb i mean by you
or someone under your direction and the
regular course of business is that your
understanding
yes
um
and
is it correct that that ecb has produced
all of video footage that uh
had been subpoenaed by
attorneys
yes that's correct
um
so to the extent that that
footage has not been produced
is it fair to say that that footage no
longer exists
or do you have another explanation
can you expand on that please
sure
um so there's my understanding is that
you testify that there's 87 clips that
have been preserved
is that right
yes
um and that the date and time stamps are
are reasonably accurate to your
knowledge on those questions
there are any missing days or times is
it fair to say that that footage no
longer exists or is there any other
footage that could be produced
outside of the videos that were
requested
that's correct no everything else would
have been written over at this point
okay so there's no
other videos other than those that have
been produced to your knowledge
yes correct
okay um
and
i believe you testify that ecb has
currently has a new and improved video
system is that right am i remembering
that correctly
yes
and back in 2016
uh would you agree with me that the
video quality was uh
somewhat grainy as i believe that we've
talked about in some of the
clips yes compared to today's yes
um and
was was uh
was it also a little bit fuzzy in the
clips that we've reviewed
today yes as they were displayed on the
screen
um and
is it correct that you did not um see
amber in person
yourself uh
may 21st for the or the several days
after
i don't recall which day
for days she came into the office
but i did see her on those two occasions
um
outside of that no i didn't see her in
person
okay um with that last answer you don't
recall
which days you saw her is that correct
i don't remember the specific date of
those uh
interactions
so would you be able to testify based on
your knowledge whether amber is wearing
makeup
uh the week of
the 21st of 2016
not that i recall
and if we could please go back um
since we have a little bit of extra time
and watch the video that we
couldn't hear the audio on there's
something wrong with it but i believe
the audio is fixed so if we could please
go back to exhibit three
mr patterson i believe you testified
when we first saw this video without
audio
uh that you described mr behave mr
depp's behavior is animated
is that right yes after now that the
audio is back would you still describe
uh mr depp's
behavior as animated
yeah i think he's still animated but
with the audio
i would say
upset about something
and based on your um
the times we've seen mr depp at ecb
have you seen him upset about
similarly upset uh
in the building
there was one video of mr deaf in the
elevator
scenes like i said earlier animated
the one you were referring to is that
the one
where you said mr depp was swaying
side to side are you thinking of a
different one
yes when you explain side to side
you know who mr waldman is
yes
who is he
uh johnny depp's attorney
did mr waldman contact you about this
case
yes what did mr waltman want when he
called you um can you click clarify just
because um
there's been several cases i don't
recall which case mr waldman was
involved in
um
so i don't believe he's reached out
regarding this
particular one to my knowledge
which um are the other cases
that you've been contacted by mr weldman
about
um i don't recall this specific one
but he did reach out to whichever one he
was representing at that time
and i believe there's a subpoena that
had followed
and did you say that mr waldman
contacted you in two prior cases
i don't recall which case it was in
regard to
and did you talk to mr wildman on the
phone
i i don't recall
and did he communicate with mr weldman
by email
yes
did mr weldman uh prepare a
draft declaration for you
yes
is it fair to say that you cannot
testify one way or another about whether
mr depp committed domestic violence
against amber
i
cannot if we could please turn to
exhibit nine
and does this look like a um video
camera from the ecb video footage this
is where you want to stop
yeah we're just going to play it
once
okay
thank you
okay
um
yes
and does this look like one uh taken and
preserved by ecb since 2016.
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time snake accurate within a few seconds
yes
could we please take that down and bring
up 10.
do and does this look like a video from
one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the clips
that was taken and preserved by acb uh
since 2016.
yes
uh and
does the date and time uh within a few
seconds look accurate
as far as you know
yes
and then quickly take that down and
bring up
16.
um
and does this look like a video clip
from one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the clips
that was taken and preserved by ecb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
and we can take this down and bring up
17 please
so
uh does this look like one of the video
clips from the ecb security cameras
yes
and it says look like look one of the
clips that was taken and preserved by
ecb from 2016
yes
and as far as you know is the date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
could please take it down and bring up
18.
[Music]
does this look like a video clip from
one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and is this like one of the clips that
was taken and preserved by acv from 2016
yes
uh and as far as you know as a date and
time stamp accurate within a few seconds
yes
could please take it down and bring up
25.
and does this look like a security uh
camera
footage from one of the acb security
cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the clips
that was taken and preserved by ecb
since 2016
yes
and as far as you know are the date and
time stamps accurate within a few
seconds
yes
if we could pull up 26.
shhh and does this look like a video
from one of the ecb security cameras
yes
and does this look like one of the clips
that was taken observed by ecb since
2016
yes
and as far as you know
is the date and time
accurate within a few seconds yes
and just to confirm that is your
signature at the end of this document is
that correct
yes that's correct
did anyone assist you in drafting this
declaration
uh yes and who was that person
uh mr waldman
and did mr waldman's assistance in
drafting your declaration have any
influence or effect on the truthfulness
of your statements in your declaration
um is this a true and accurate copy of
your first witness
statement submitted in the uk action yes
it appears to be
mr patterson the statements contained in
this first witness statement are they
truthful yes anything that i would have
put on here and sign would have been
truthful
did mr depp ever offer you any money
no he did not
between may 21 2016 which i'll represent
to you was a saturday
and may 27 2016 which i will represent
to you was a friday did you work on site
at the eastern columbia building
i don't recall if i was there those days
i'm typically there monday through
friday but i do not recall if i was
there those days
sitting here today do you have any
recollection of interacting in person
with miss heard at any point between may
21st 2016 and may 27 2016.
as i had previously mentioned i i don't
recall specific dates of when
this herd stopped by the office um
i i don't know how this specific debates
alejandra romero was another person that
spoke to you about his interactions with
miss heard
that i don't
i'm not 100
i
i don't recall exactly
was cornelius harrell one of the people
that spoke to you about his interactions
with miss heard
i also don't recall a specific
interaction for me lewis do you recall
when mrs sparza first came to you about
her observations of miss heard
i don't recall a specific interaction i
have a recollection of
uh
i guess trinity stopping by
but don't i don't remember the exact
interaction
now the statements contained in
paragraphs 15 through 18
truthful as i review it
yes that is my recollection of the
occurrences
what footage do you recall miss esparza
showing you okay
i recall miss esparza showing me video
of the mezzanine level
uh where the
multi-colored
area rug is
um of amber with her sister
and
rocky
and one of them
when i remember
fake punched amber in the face
um
in which they all started laughing and
then they walked off screen
you recall the date of that surveillance
footage video that you just described
i do not
do you recall whether it occurred after
may 21 2016.
i i don't recall
mr patterson does this after reviewing
paragraph seven of your declaration that
you signed under the penalty of perjury
does this refresh your recollection as
to whether or not you observe the
surveillance footage
sometime around may 24th 2016.
yes
okay let's let's go through the first
interaction that you remember
with miss heard can you tell me what you
remember about that interaction
so
amber came in shook her hand
um
and she
told me the situation where she needed
to
have me make a statement to her sources
at people magazine
did miss her explain to you why she
wanted you to speak to her source at
people magazine
i don't remember the exact i don't
recall the exact uh ask
it was something to do with her getting
ridiculed in the eye of the public
opinion or something like that
please have exhibit three pulled up
and for the record it's bait stamped
depth
three six two eight
hmm
so
mr patterson does this video clip
represented through accurate copy of one
of the original clips that was produced
in response to a subpoena in this in
2016.
yes
and was this clip recorded and kept in
the regular course of business for
eastern columbia management
i misspoke let me rephrase
was this clip recorded and kept in the
regular course of business for eastern
columbia building
can you expand on that
yeah let me rephrase it um
this is surveillance footage this is a
clip of surveillance footage that
was recorded
for business purposes at ecb yes
yes that is correct okay
and it was kept
or preserved by ecb
right
yes that is correct
do you know that which camera uh this
particular clip
was showing footage from
we can perhaps replay it because i
believe
it might indicate that
do you know which camera this is showing
uh footage from
so this would have been the penthouse
elevator
and if we could please pull up exhibit
four
do
uh
so
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that
was produced in in response to subpoena
in 2016
uh it appears to be
there's nothing going on right now but
yes
and which camera is this showing footage
from
uh this is also the penthouse elevator
if i could please have exhibit five
pulled up
do
so
um
and for the record
that's bait stamped depth three six four
one
so
and does this video clip represent a
true and accurate copy of one of the
original clips that was produced in just
in
2016.
uh yes it appears to be
do you know which camera this is showing
footage from
this would also be the penthouse
elevator
and what is the date of this footage
may 21st 2016.
okay if you could please pull up exhibit
six
bait stamped depth 3648
so
hmm
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that you produced
in 2016
uh it appears to
it appears so i don't recall this exact
time of the split but yes it
it does appear stuff
and is it uh what is the date on this
video clip
may 21st 2016.
and which camera is this showing footage
from
um if they can wait for the doors to
open
uh so this is also the penthouse
elevator
mr patterson i will show you next a
video clip that's been bait stamped depp
3610
patterson exhibit seven
does this video clip
present a true and accurate copy of one
of the original clips that was produced
in 2016
yes it appears to be so
do you know which camera this is showing
footage from
this is the front desk camera in the
lobby
next can we please have exhibit eight
pulled up
which for the record is dep3620
mr patterson does this video clip
represent a true and accurate copy of
one of the original clips that was
produced in 2016
uh yes it appears to be some do you
recognize who the person is that entered
the elevator at 22.56
um it appears to be ever heard
can i please have exhibit nine pulled up
um
oh
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
yes it appears to be so
do you know which camera this is showing
footage from
uh this is also the penthouse salary
can i please have exhibit 10 hold up
so
and for the record this is bait stamped
depth 3607. does this appear to be
video clip
of a true and accurate copy of one of
the original clips that was produced in
2016.
uh yes it appears to be son
and do you know which camera this is
showing footage from
this is also the penthouse elevator
and what date is depicted
may 25th 2016.
next can i have please exhibit 12 which
for the record is fade stamp depth 3572
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016.
okay
uh yes it appears to be some
and do you know which camera this is
showing footage from
this is the front desk lobby camera
and what is the date of this video clip
may 25th 2016.
and if we could please go to
really if i could ask for your help
13.45
i'm going to mark this exhibit as
patterson exhibit 12.
do you recognize the woman
at the desk walking to the desk
yes it looks like amber heard is
approaching trinity as far as working at
the desk
can i have exhibit 13 pulled up please
and for the record it's bait stamped
depth three five eight three
okay
up
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
uh yes it appears to be so
and do you know which camera this is
showing footage from
uh this would also be the penthouse
elevator
and what is the date of this video clip
may 25th 2016.
do you recognize the woman in the black
shirt just outside the elevator
uh yes amber hurt so is this one of the
video clips that represents true and
accurate copy of the original eclipse
that was produced in 2016.
uh yes it appears to be so
and what is the date of this video clip
may 25th 2016.
what camera angle
or excuse me
what camera is this showing footage
footage from
this is the mezzanine camera between the
building and the parking garage
is that camera four
according to the stamp yes
thank you if you could please mark that
as exhibit 14.
turning to
patterson exhibit 15
bait stamped depth 3569
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
uh yes appreciable
and uh what is the date of this video
may 25th 2016.
and which cameras is showing footage
from
uh this is camera seven lobby camera and
does this video clip represent through
an accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
uh yes it appears to be some and what is
the date of this video
may 24th 2016.
and uh what camera is this showing
footage from
this is camera number six which is the
kiosk camera outside on broadway
thank you can we please mark this
security clip as patterson exhibit 16.
next can i please have patterson exhibit
17
depp
359
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced
in 2016
uh yes it appears to be sun
and what camera is is showing footage
from
uh this is camera number eight
um broadway outside of the permanent
building
what is the date of this video
may 24 2016.
thank you please mark this security clip
as patterson exhibit 17.
almost done turning to video clip that
has been baked stamp depth
3609 patterson exhibit 18.
does this video clip represent a true
and accurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
uh yes it appears to lisa
and do you know which camera this is
showing footage from
this is camera 4
which is a service hallway
and what date is depicted in the
security clip
may 22nd 2016.
thank you can we please mark this video
clip as patterson exhibit 18.
next patterson exhibit 19
depth 3611
does this video clip represent a true
inaccurate copy of one of the original
clips that was produced in 2016
uh yes it appears to be some
and uh what camera is this showing
footage from
this is camera 13 nez main
level
and what is the date on this video clip
may 22nd 2016.
thank you can we please mark the
security clip as patterson exhibit 19.
turning to patterson exhibit 20
which for the record is bait stamped
depth 3612
this is one of the video clips that
represents a true and correct copy
of one of the original clips that was
produced in 2016.
uh yes it appears to be said
and what camera is this showing footage
from
uh this is the garage camera number two
and what is the date of this video clip
may 22nd 2016.
thank you can we please mark the
security clip as patterson exhibit 20.
and do you know what camera this is
showing footage from
this is parking garage camera number 14.
and what is the date on this video clip
may 22nd 2016.
thank you can we please mark the
security clip as patterson exhibit 21.
mr patterson i believe you previously
testified
for council informed you that there were
87 video clips that were produced
in response to a subpoena in 2016. do
you recall that testimony
yes
and um all 87 video clips
the best of your recollection as the
person most knowledgeable for
property
excuse me action property management
were those
87 video clips
recorded and kept or preserved
in the regular course of business for
eastern columbia building
yes
and were those clips collected preserved
and produced near the time of the actual
events recorded in the clips
uh
yes it would have been within that 20 to
30 day timeline
right
and it was the regular practice of the
eastern columbia building to record
security footage similar to what is
reflected in these clips that you've
been shown today correct
yes that's correct
patterson i believe
uh you testified earlier that you
commented on
revisions to mr weldman's draft
declaration is that right
yes that's correct
and i would like you to read please the
comment uh the third comment down um
which says was this footage found
i'm i'm not certain of the date or time
i also do not recall who she was with
but it was two females i do not recall
who threw the pretend punch i also do
not recall if if she had any signs of
injury during this time however i do
recall one of the females pretending to
punch amber um
in the face
now
did you write this comment
uh
do you remember it
i
do recall uh vaguely
and
this this this footage never was found
is that correct
the footage was never requested
by whom
any of the attorneys
so the footage
if it was is it your testimony that that
this exists this footage exists or not
it would no longer exist
and it would no longer exist and it was
never produced as one of the 87 clips
is that right that is correct
and
i believe you testified earlier that
attorneys for both sides selected times
and looked through
video and made selections of what to
preserve is that is that was that your
testimony yes that's correct
but nobody selected that footage
to your knowledge not to my knowledge
now
and it was never produced
that's my knowledge now
um
and is it correct that uh
that you do not recall
at that time whether amber had any signs
of injury
at this moment no i do not recall
and according to that comment you did
not recall at that time is that your
understanding i don't recall
and you don't know the date or the time
of that
footage don't recall and obviously i
could read this but i don't recall
offhand
and you didn't recall at the time either
is that right
that's correct
all right that completes testimony
correct all right ladies and gentlemen
thank you for your extra time tonight i
just wanted to get through that witness
tonight so we could start with a new
witness tomorrow okay so have a good
evening again don't do any outside
research don't talk to anybody about the
case probably stay off social media i
would appreciate it okay and we'll see
in the morning at 10 am okay
all right
okay well
i know six weeks sound like a lot of
time
but um
it's only 24 days and we've already done
three days so you have 21 days left you
know stipulations is one of my favorite
words so you might want to consider
looking back through all the evidence
that you have and stipulate on a lot of
information because i promised the story
would be done by memorial day weekend
and we will be done by memorial day
weekend so when your time is up your
time is up
my law clerk sammy is tracking
everybody's time who's how much time has
been used by each side so you'll keep
doing that throughout the trial and
we'll let you know on a weekly basis how
it's going but if things don't speed up
in the deposition you're just not going
to get through this so i want you to
keep that in mind okay
all right um any remote witnesses
tomorrow do if we need to set that up
no more okay all right great thank you
have a good evening we'll see you at 10
o'clock okay
you